round 11 up the Sinquefield cup one of
the strongest tournaments in chess
history with as many as eight players
still in the hunt the elite of world
chess came into the final round
desperate to win world champion Magnus
Carlsen once again proved why he's the
best in the game has a big win over
Maxine passionate Rob vaulted him into a
tie for first with Chinese superstar
dangler in two heavyweight fighters look
to crush each other with a cup on the
line the deciding action-packed playoffs
coming on
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the final day
of the 2019 single Cup held here at the
st. Louis just Club this is it the
championship day the day when the victor
is going to be decided we have a mini
match between magnus carlsen the world
champion and ding Lorraine
what's going to happen who is going to
take the cup home let's go to the studio
and find out with Yassir Jen and Maurice
Thank You Christian and good morning I'm
Jennifer Sajadi and I am here with
yasser and maurice and what a treat do
we have for you a playoff for all the
marbles of the Sinquefield cup hello
Jennifer hello Maurice hello everyone a
pleasure to be with you as we settle who
will be the champion of the 2019 Cinco
Cup we had an extraordinary finish
leading to a surprising tie break let's
take a look at how the tournament ended
and the Grantchester points awarded
Jennifer well ding lauren and magnus
carlsen finished at the top of the table
16 and a half grand gesture points six
and a half points in the tournament that
was plus two the chasers behind Sergey
acharyaji and Vichy Anna and her need 35
K and 11 points you don't see the prize
money yet for Lorena and magnus carlsen
and that's because not only are they
playing for the prestigious title they
are also playing for bonus money as the
90km 60k will be pulled together the
winner will get 80 thousand to over
80,000 already $2,500 to be precise and
this brings us to this point well this
is a head-to-head score between Magnus
Carlsen and bingler and it looks like a
massive edge for Magnus and it is 19 to
4 with 21 draws but as Maurice will
explain more a little later that's it
could be a little bit misleading because
many of those games took place in one
match here in st. Louis
exactly don't count Bing out and the
reefs will explain why but let's take a
look at the format for these playoffs
Jeff well it's gonna be a two-game rapid
match game 25 with the ten-second delay
throughout if that's on decide
either by alternating victories or by
two draws we will go on to a series of
blitz matches there'll be two game foots
matches if any of them are decided the
match is over and the Cup is decided if
they're undecided we'll keep doing more
blitz matches if we have three and it's
still a standstill
the chief arbiter will make a decision
whether to do more blitz go to
Armageddon and that is unlikely though
probably if we play four matches
somebody will become the jab indeed and
then we're expecting that
after the tiebreaker we'll have the
ultimate moves within thirty minutes
thereafter oh yes we will with garry
kasparov indeed but right now we've got
Maurice Ashley to talk to us about how
these two gladiators got to the top of
the table well it simply has been an
amazing event it started off a bit
slowly but the end is all we could have
hoped for
we saw it so tight so tense throughout
and an improbable finish to be sure
let's take a look at how these players
got here first of all Chinese superstar
two in Lorain he played solidly at the
beginning and then he turned on the Jets
he had that great win some say one of
the great wins of the year against a
niche Giri
in round five and then another fabulous
win against Fabiano Caruana showing his
style not only on offense but also on
defense he was on the ropes a few games
and managed to show his tenacity and
determination to survive and he
rightfully is here in this final
playoffs but someone will say who who
brought this guy to the party we thought
he was dead ninth rose in a row magnus
carlsen
languishing in the middle of the pack
for so long but like a champ when it
counted he knocked out Wesley so in
round 10 and then talk about a blow body
blows from every direction against back
seam varela Grove in the final round
that's how champions get it done and
Magnus here now playing for the title
and what's the history behind these two
well Magnus fans will smile the
champions showdown two years ago right
here in st. Louis
simply a wipeout Magnus winning ten to
one in the rapids and six to one in the
blitz
you couldn't imagine ding lorraine
coming back from something that horrific
but he did just a couple of weeks ago
and in their one-on-one matchup ping
Lorinda smash magnus with a brilliant
queen sacrifice one we all remember and
then in blitz
they broke even so recent history will
have chinese fans smiling to be sure but
it passes the past it's all about what
you got for me today baby and it should
be an exciting matchup as magnus carlsen
now arriving in the building this should
be a thrilling match for the same feel
Cup lutely thank you so much Maurice and
let's just take a look at the grand
Chester standings now that the sync bill
cup is in the books here's where we
stand
reminding everybody that it's the top
four that will make it to the finals in
London begin with the euro Geoff well
it's gonna be really tricky to get in
there but not for Magnus Carlsen his
spot is locked up and the keys thrown
away sealed the deal
that's right but he will be playing one
more event the tata steel event in india
ding moran also looking phenomenal as he
just needs to win a few games and the
other events and he's golden and MBL has
wrapped up his taurus you see he's
played in the five events that's
required Levon Aronian looking to pass
MBL has only played three events to
events for him as we see
getting ready for tiebreak and what a
performance
this man has achieved in his tiebreak
outings guys I mean he's never lost what
can you say about perfection for loss of
time besides if Ulis I mean it's off the
chart we will see but that's completely
that's that's sick you you must lose
sooner or later but this guy's trying to
make it later than sooner and by the way
he did show up early today we've noted
that he always got to the board in the
classical about a minute or two late but
he's not going to give any minutes away
this time so now let's go up to chief
arbiter Chris Byrd with final
instructions you see Chris there looking
relaxed okay
welcome to the same field Cup Playoffs
just gentlemen just a couple of quick
things
before we start here the regulations for
today we're going to play a two-game
mini match a rapid if we're tied at the
end of this we will then move on to
blitz mini matches while the games are
in progress the playing area for this
for these events are to the refreshment
table over here and if you need to use
the restroom just use this one right
here the prize fund the winner will take
eighty two thousand five hundred and the
runner-up will take sixty seven thousand
five hundred dollars spectators please
while you're up here at all times we
need complete silence and quiet so
please respect that at all times if you
need to go and talk please move out of
the playing area and go downstairs into
the lobby gentlemen we're going to be
using the same regulations that were in
the rapid and blitz tournaments that
also means that draw offers are now
permitted so and if anyone needs to make
a claim please the usual stuff to stop
the clock and the abacus will help you
and deal with that
does anyone have any questions before we
begin
okay Magnus we'll have the white pieces
in the first game there'll be a minimum
of ten minutes between rounds I'll
announce to the next round time as soon
as this round is over good luck
gentlemen please go ahead start White's
clock and they are off as this tie
breaks under way we've just had two
marks of Queensberry rules explained to
us and quickly d4 no Knight c3
Queens gambit declined are we gonna see
Bishop e7 Bishop f4 are we gonna see
Bishop before or d5 takes c4 possibly
small hesitation on ding Lorenz part
already he could not have been fully
surprised to see this come on the board
not at all but he is just taking his
time to decide exactly which variation
he wants to play as he knows Magnus is
well-prepared pretty much for everything
and a bit of time seems I was about to
say at the end of my professional career
c76
was the move that everybody liked to
play the pod Vinik pawn sacrifice that
results from Bishop g5 takes on c4 and
efore looks like a slight surprise to
Magnus to see it and now g-33 whoa okay
that is quite the surprise I must say
why is that such a surprise to you yes
because um is it the c-4 upon that it's
not that easy now after defect well he's
going for it with 95 OS about to say
it's not super easy to win back that
pawn on c4 because you don't want to
play III or e4 because you're planning
on putting your bishop on g2 and
concisely but okay 95 and are you just
gonna defend it with b5 indeed that's
that's the main variation as b5 Bishop
g2
and 95 is one of you know really really
complex line that black could undertake
now black once he could also just allow
white to recover the pond with a move
like 97 forcing Knight takes e4 white as
use it spending a lot of time of course
and he played nine BT seven eight
he did play Knight be 87 all right so I
know you're entertaining a Cheerios and
keep that pod I sure did okay after
Knight takes e4 it seems like you're so
surprised by White's treatment is
there's anything like lesser than this
advantage the normal I mean white still
has a good opening position not oh yes
Bishop on CA that does run and let's
just say for example b5 played mm-hmm
now where are you gonna move your knight
you go back to e5 that could be a trade
of knights
however Queens yes this is a solid
treatment for example you could have a
situation like this where basically
black aspires to play the move c6 c5 if
he does get in see 65 and probably I
made a mistake I apologize I just put
Queen b6 on the board if black ever
manages to get c5 you can imagine how
easily he might be able to make an equal
my quality Knight back to e5 trades
master eights happening very quickly you
see the Knight takes pawn takes and now
King takes on d1 keeping his night on
that c3 square
I think oh that's a tonight G the
surprise Knight g4 does look to all the
world like a fork 94 how do you stop the
capture well we can play Bishop g2 and
then if Knight f2 q 192 h1 hello Bishop
takes c6 and I I am now counted no
longer play Bishop takes a 8 and your
Knights tracked right exactly
a P so you're saying for how many pawns
no a grand total of zero
exactly this is I took c6 and you took E
F - G - you have to take a time out but
now don't I have night takes B five
possibilities I'm going to cancel with
check I see so I better slow down hold
my horses
yeah and this guy is hanging - don't
forget so no bueno so instead let's try
after Bishop e7 my thought is that if I
protect my EEP on now yeah if I play
Kimi one now and you play Knight e5 now
I have Knight takes b5 right and this is
not the end of the world for why it is
it no I mean I think it's a little weird
looking but why does spending a lot of
time having his King around the board
and then it could be like a move like
Bishop before check actually Bishop
before check would actually provoke me
to play Knight c3 you couldn't play
Bishop d2 because again I've got that
castles which what about King upon he's
don't like that no on the contrary I
love it for black hahahahaha gift me a
mate he did not go for Knight g4 he
avoided in the most principled line
suspecting a rat from Magnus and put the
night instead on d5 more solid to be
sure but he doesn't have some slight
weaknesses he would have to defend that
said the ignorant has been a maestro at
defending in this event so far so he
just didn't take any chances with Knight
to g4 and Magnus now looking at this
move I'm pretty sure Magnus was
eyeballing Knight g4 and had some kind
of reply for that sharp enough Magnus
has been shown that he's willing to sack
on e5 quick question here Maurice
how often is King takes d1 showing up in
the database this is too fast it's going
too fast for me to even look in that
direction but because I was maybe
barking maybe barking let us know but I
mean with 94 Hynes are so fascinating
I'm a little sad they didn't take place
exactly ninety five instead much more
solid move and
what should we do now is Wyatt just
Bishop d2 ready to play Bishop d2 is
excellent the idea is that any trades we
can take another move I might just you
take a look at your Bishop on CA for
just a moment you get the idea that it
is really doesn't have a great life
imagine I play something really silly
takes takes and I just want to put a
silly situation on the board f3
there's Bishop okay if you kept it on c8
it would be stuck behind an e6 pawn
right if you put it on Bishop d7 and
then you play a move like C 65 you want
to give your Bishop life you'll be
hitting a brick wall on e4 and f3 so
White was gonna go king c2 a4 and it's
gonna make it very difficult for blacks
Bishop to ever come to life neither of
those moves were ramanga says twice in
fact you played Knight to e4 but really
fascinating structural lesson you gave
us there he is waiting on granite they
call it it's 94 played instead and then
Bishop e7 quick reply from being Moran
and now Bishop g2 on the board I'm gonna
tell you the engines really don't like
Magnus's position at all that King being
a little bit on safe exposed it castles
Queen side right now then there's a
discovered threat in the position and
the King on C 2 will be tickled at some
point also there's a big idea of playing
c5 eventually for black so castles king
C to c5 taking over space being able to
go to b4 with Czech there's that long
diagonal you have to worry about
constantly this one could end up poorly
if the rent is aggressive with castles
well let's imagine we start that's
really interesting because when I look
at this position it's to me it's like
bad King versus bad bishop and normally
you know hey in an endgame maybe the bad
bishop is gonna be more important
because it's more permanent but this is
not an endgame yet Oh
in fact that King in the center of the
board gives black some very nice
attacking looking options so after
castles let's assume Bishop d2 you're
right Murray's king c2 night before
check looks like a very annoying look at
Bishop d2 okay on a good day if I get in
the moves rooks e5 pardon me
rook c1 and 95 together that combination
would would be nice for white g5 r z5
can I be so greedy as to capture on c5
and I take c5 Bishop takes e5 rook c1
well don't forget there's nicely there's
a knight at three problem
there sure is and this is not the
Bishop's of opposite color that I was
dreaming about when I picked off the
pawn on c5 even before taking on c5 I
mean with that Knight was hanging and
he's played c5 immediately he's
understanding what this position is
about and his bishop is no longer a bad
piece he always has tactics on the long
diagonal Bishop d2 see position you
mentioned and now he could Castle
queenside but he does have to watch out
for this tactic you talked about well
rook c1 see ya castles kings a
queen-sized pardon me is the move I'd
really like to play maybe black could
simply dodge those Knight takes e5 ideas
by playing C 5 C 4 C 5 is so strong
castles is so dynamic yeah so I mean if
your Castle queenside by the way you're
95 let's just go down this line 95 can
be met by 93 not to take on a c5 and you
got a pawn but look at your tripled pawn
I'm not happy at all no I mean those
variation I'm gonna work out badly well
okay but then how about rook c1 now in
case of c4
okay not is now a good time to take the
time to play King to c2 and maybe try to
park my king on v1 also strongest black
is night the
six sorry what work c1 Knight b6 rook c1
Knight b6 pinning your knight and
threatening Knight see for hitting the
knight to the bishop on g2 1994 I mean
black is just sort of taken over the
initiative right now and white is busy
trying to keep the game going but not
the black guys not interfere here mm-hmm
no Knight takes I was looking at some
Knight takes e5 cheapos Bishop takes g2
Knight takes c6 discovered check there's
some strange lines Bishop g2 96 King b8
also have Knight c4 and he played
passively instead by the way that line
is you can track his rook after ninety
five just to get your okay sorry so
Knight b6 might be 695 rook d2 getting
the rook out of the way so you have no
Disco's mm-hmm and then take and now you
have no meaningful discovery in this
position especially is it's gonna be met
in 94 check as well check check so two
yeah two pieces for the rook here so he
had that aggressive line with castles
but he didn't he played Bishop e7 but if
a bit of a blink on ding Lauren's part
of Bishop e7 well the strange part is
that the move Bishop e7 to my mind it's
preparing to Castle short I like the
idea that blacks king could take a part
in the battle on the queenside castling
short and tucking the king away is all
nice and good but this could easily
become an endgame very shortly and the
King on g8 isn't much slower I think he
blinked when he had the chance right now
against magnets he's probably thinking
he just needs a draw with black play
solid don't go for the sharpest lines
get the white pieces and go win it that
way but you get a chance against Magnus
hey I can tell you if Magnus had the
black pieces I don't believe you I'm
coming after you I'm playing the sharp
line I'm coming to kill you it's very
clear that you've got to take down the
champ you can't just back away and
and play solid chests and and hope you
make it you know with the numbers cuz
that's not how Magnus is gonna lose well
maybe it was just this idea of castling
short to avoid all these 95 ideas yes
but that's the point avoiding risk okay
can I just play ultra-aggressive a move
really you would like to play when I've
connected my rooks and brought them to
the center I better take ya you better
take it right Knight d6 check takes
takes so I've undone my pawns and I'm
ready please play Knight III check so
that if you take and then I got this
pawn over here or conversely please play
Knight e3 check and at the end of the
day I'll pick up right King d7 King d7
so then I was thinking about this move
before Knight f6 now you can't play e5
because the Bishop g2 and now your
Knight g4 and maybe II so this is the
problem right like you're it's taking
you time to collect the pawn on d6 but
hey if you do collect the pawn it's
gonna be good for you so 96 premature I
need tonight yeah with rook c1 Magnus is
95 by the way was we've been told was a
novelty that way back by playing this
move 95 you could feel that it didn't
really work out for him not enough no
not 85 no I move eight on move eight
when he played 95 the first time right
here g3 95 in this position which is
somewhat surprising given that could
that be a novel no you said movie that
is movie no you mean the other one you
mean after b5 that's movie right oh yes
my pod okay this is puzzling to me
because this is in a novel - he made
over the board or is it something you
prepared because if he prepared it
because now it looks like you know
you're blundering upon so maybe he
mostly looked in 94 and not 95 because
94 variations
even though use you seem to think they
were suspicious the lines that we
actually looked at it turned out okay
for riot because there was those tactics
yeah that's why maybe maybe his team
spent a lot of time on 94 and then less
on 95 and that's the explanation for why
he didn't get such a good position even
though he presumably prepared this by
the way just double-check what is our
current times pretty balanced guys okay
I mean it looks like we're about to be
exactly balanced because they both have
an e team and it's a 53 seconds right
now right now not anymore anyway jump on
it okay big moment here actually because
another approach that Magnus could take
is let's suppose Magnus were to play the
move a four okay and just say okay I'm
comfortable with this stasis that has
occurred in the center here keep your
knight on d5 I'm going to keep my knight
on e4 on a good day way down the line
I'm gonna play f4 but in the meantime
before well and it's it's
awkward because unless you
gain control over the c-4 square okay
so let's just go down this path for a
second c8 defending rook c8 96 or now
so now if Bishop takes g5 maybe 96 well
no the rook on c1 is hanging there which
is yeah that is yeah and that's a pity I
apologize I can't get in
I think Magnussen himself is struggling
with how to get this game going as you
see him burn a lot of clock in this
rapid gainer Tinley is so he knows this
is a very important moment in the game
as black is prepared to castle either
side most likely we see black looking to
go Kings side but black could also keep
the king in the middle of the board as
well although this Bishop e7 move
intimates that he wants to go Kings side
and not giving Magnus any chances but
there's gonna be a very easy game for
black to play that's probably the
biggest difficulty here blacks play is
so easy castles bring the rooks to the
middle start pushing pawns white needs
to figure something out specifically and
don't forget that King on d1 it
obviously cannot castle anymore
so Magnus has to do some kind of fixing
of his position that's gonna take a few
Tempe to get it fixed
King c2 greeting the rooks together for
the King on b1 that's four moves black
takes one move to Castle and his two
rooks get into the game really fast and
then he gets to play with no weaknesses
to speak of blacks got to be okay here
so Magnus wants to make sure that he's
okay and I think that's why he has to be
careful about not trying any kinds of a4
ideas because because he doesn't have
anything real to chew on in blacks
position and he spent eight minutes
right now looking at it in a rapid game
that's pretty remarkable eight minutes
well look at Magnus he is not
comfortable talking 25% of your allotted
time and Kathy emits a 10-second delay
it's a 10-second delay that's right so
that's a third of your time a third of
his time on one move
they can't get any and he hasn't moved
yet so and by the way it's not like ding
Lauren has quite something spectacularly
off-balance that you didn't look at I
mean c5 Bishop d7 these are really
natural moves so I'm really surprised by
this very long very long but maybe it'll
prove to be smart guys because he senses
this is a critical moment with 96 ideas
for c1 and after that he'll probably
play a lot of moves quickly
I don't know Jen this is starting to to
remind me of the rapid in blitz he
didn't do well in the rapid in blitz he
was not comfortable after a long thing
now he has played rook to c1 he showed
that form the classical form in the last
two games of this event the Sinquefield
Cup but in the rapid and blitz this is
what he was doing
guessing himself second-guessing himself
third guessing himself what should I be
doing here he was not in flow we'll see
if that is what is about to happen or
will this move that took him so long be
just a prelude as you said to some quick
moves we don't we don't really know yet
all right well obviously the move rook
c1 does attack the pawn on c5 is two
things that black can do he can either
defend them that the pawn with the move
rook c8 which looks very logical or he
could advance the partner with the move
a c5 c4 gaining space and essentially
asking white are you prepared to play
the move b2 b3 or not quite bad who
which one is he gonna play there's only
two moose rook c8 my guess as well I
think he's gonna play solid to analyze
the ramifications of b3 well he was
playing solidly to this point so I was
trying to guess from the nature of his
play this one a little bit more loose as
b3 had to be calculated its but he seems
comfortable with this particular move
and now the King quickly trying to hop
to that b1 square he did play king c2
yes please
know
to be three because there was a chance
that after b-two b-three he could have
just just that black ding Lorraine could
have played 85 again the King isn't that
comfortable if the King was on GE one it
would be much better off but King be
king c2 preparing to as Maurice was
saying play King B there's an f5
sighting there's an f5 sighting in the
position that will be very sharp right
now Magnus will have to figure out what
to do as there are some discoveries that
lead to his Bishop being captured on g2
and then the King may not get back home
in town eh Knight takes Knight takes f6
is a check right so you have to speak
with the pawn you want to take with the
PS the point Allante to take with the
pawn and reinvigorate the threat of f5
well shortly but if you could take the
night and it wasn't check it might be
actually what do you mean T really all
right so it could be devastating right
but what would it look like
f5 so if you go f5 I could believe might
be four checks here right yeah if you
get the d3 square for your night yeah
then you know you're just like so now
finally okay he sold that saw he finally
opted for this sharp move I happy to see
that move by wait for ding leerin I
think that the King on the g8 Square
would actually misplace the king and I
think that King on the Queen side or in
the center really makes the most sense
after f5 it was really promising now
King b1 and a fight might not be quite
as strong anymore
why do I have to play it right right
away why don't I just bring my rooks to
the open D file and I ball Bishop on D 2
so all the moves by the way we were
talking about the King fixing itself the
rooks coming to the open files working
one plate instead of how it happens but
this is what we were talking about
that's you need we needed to fix his
position that Magnus and he needed to
play all these moves right so the king
up the rook up Diggler in would play
rook d7 and double as well yeah so
Bishop g5 is never too good because you
do have a sex
well a moment ago you were going to play
f6f-5 now on the very hard guessing
where he's going because he mixes
solidity with with dynamism right now
his last few moves have been dynamic he
started off very solid so let me not do
anything crazy but in the last few moves
c4 Castle queenside and f5 shows his
state of mind and Knight g5 indeed a
knight c3 loses immediately tonight
before track 95 also loses to Bishop
takes g5 Bishop takes d5 might be for
track so both of those moves are out
right I mean it leaves only e5 takes f6
yeah I mean either that or 96 Jack
there's no alternative Magnus is nervous
now is is 96 check is the only other
candidate move but that would just
sacrifice a pawn and I don't see that
that leading to anything but that's a
gaseous Irawan pawn right there yeah but
he takes that six so therefore you take
that 6s force no Knight g5 is force
he takes f6 Bishop takes d5 and then
Bishop takes d5 okay right Bishop takes
d5 nice in between move wild line breaks
out what you want
losing a pawn but rate you're losing 85
huh yeah but there's a bishops of
opposite all right right you hope if you
survive this position right yeah okay so
smart idea there 95 and indeed Magnus is
thinking it over as he sees this idea he
has been outplayed though Magnus has
been out playing this game in about last
few moves
not accurate and Magnus trying to decide
now as he realizes he's to get in the
defensive mindset but let's say he is
he's not sacrifice a pawn and keep it
going
yeah well 96 check Bishop takes d6 e 5
takes d6 all on the board we're
anticipating take the pawn so similar to
the other pawn sacrifice he's
anticipating sometimes there's gonna be
this bishops of opposite color and game
you right where he can't hold on and
indeed he goes for that right away so
for some reason he like this move order
better than the Knight g5 idea Bishop
takes d5 right now and maybe because he
wants to put the bishop on c3 as I think
that might be why because with it on g5
it would be harder to reroute it to that
nice diagonal
well I'm thinking just the opposite I'm
thinking that he sacrificed upon
purposely to try to get a draw but if he
could play King c3 King before aha and
okay you know like you know for example
Bishop f4 and if I could get my King
over here that that's really really you
know gorgeous dark square blockade now
having said that gen Bishop c3 looks
like a very decent getting as you say
you're the bishop on the long diagonal
Maurice there's an amazing decision
though that all of us as humans would
not want to do but the engine saying
this is the best way to take on d5 is to
take with the pawn take with the pawn
shut down everything white is trying to
do and get this line so for example
Bishop c3 can be met by this intimate so
hitting this pawn and if you save it
then g5 and block is playing for
initiative in this position maybe an F
for maybe play on this side sorry and
with rook eight six as well so he gets a
lot of play and this is probably what
DeLaurentis considering this is not what
we would do as humans we see the full
scale dark square blockade this bishop
looks poor but it can be rerouted later
can go back at c8 and find this
potential f4 and find this diagonal but
this mass of pawns also heal
to worry that a five might happen
sometime in the game so this is
counterintuitive
but very strong at least enterprising
the other lines Magnus might be thinking
about getting that drawing blockade set
up as we mentioned but this opening the
line with this capture would be really
interesting as we said counterintuitive
let's see whether or not ding Lorraine
finds this idea I love it once you see
it it looks so appealing especially with
it's like a g5 and f4 and it looks like
ding the Wren is carefully considering
his three options here as and well I
think that this is just an incredibly
important fork in the road of the game
no question about it I love the movie
six takes d5 from the structural point
of view Black has a queen side majority
three to two on the Queen side but if
you could go ecigs takes d5 followed by
D 5 D four oh he's got any artists Wow a
nice recapture with the pawn to bring
his essentially as Maurice was saying
the rook on e8 comes to life and a huge
social scene three rookie three on the
board okay I'll be Ricky 8 e 2 e 3 and
now this move g5 and I love this
opportunity from blacks point of view
but being able to play for rook h6
hanging her assing this h2 pawn and one
pawn more for black and the initiative
all the initiative was who result game
what's another line Magnus is not
solidified the position at all and he
will have to watch out as g5 is on the
board ding Lauren playing Lane boss
chest right he's playing well he's
playing wonderfully well really really
aggressive I can't even find a target
that deep on well defended by the bishop
for the moment it doesn't look like
White has any way to pierce the
structure the beautiful thing to is b3
and a for those things won't affect
blacks position you'll just have passed
pawns you do things like that yeah you
can trade off if you want a six will
keep everything solid and he'll just get
passed pawns for you to stare at plus
you're down upon and your
have to worry like what do you do about
rook h6 as a threat I think I have to
start with the move rook d4 great in
order to meet rook h6 with h4 I've got
one trap in the position and seem to
recall a game from my junior days is
like in the Garfield High School I once
had a situation where my opponent
unwittingly went inside and I trap the
rook like that so I'm thinking that
Magnus has to play the move rook d4 he
ordered me but he did okay in order to
meet rook h6 with h4 and at least offer
trade of rooks and maybe on a good day
if Y could get rook g1 again he's
playing for a blockade he's trying to
draw the game he's trying to just but
there's no question exactly and you know
if he can if he can get his Bishop to d4
and his king to c3 we talked about that
dark square blockade he will be close
working for blade instead for rook efore
okay and his main point is to play for
that rook e8 six idea as well trading
off a pair of rooks that that could
backfire
that could backfire as you simplify the
game and make it a little bit easier for
white but as long as he keeps a pair of
rooks on the board then he should still
have some initiative okay rookie four
let's see what we couldn't do my first
instinct would be to take the rook and I
want to play depending okay take with
the F pawn because that way your F pawn
is also a weakness yes I don't have work
f6 because that square is guarded so I'm
gonna have to move my work back in order
to attack exactly and let's go h4 now if
I can get you to play g4 okay then the
idea was that I'm getting I mean it's
not like your height squared okay what
am i play work f7 Bishop f4 d4 is that
possible
oh you're not gonna fall fine I've just
gonna I'm just gonna go king seat well
before should be played right you should
play b4 and okay yeah try to you should
to move the rook because yeah I see a
Bishop d6 coming let's put our seems
like there's some Intel tactics in all
these lines this one played play for b4
n a5 probably a 5 yeah here I just eat
the bishops of opposite color yes is
making a very 6 by the way working for
work h1 on the board looking for work h1
on the board sorry Jenny right so we're
catch one right away so rather look h1
yeah ok
we're catch one immediately ok white
White's leaving the detention keeping
right makes a lot of sense because that
means that there's no reason for you to
think that the F file is half open yeah
I like that idea better much better
nice little tweak on the same defensive
idea and but I think from Magnus's point
of view of magnets can get an h4 provoke
the move g5 g4 and then you know rook a
1 and get it okay you closer to address
chip on b7 appearing on either efore or
d3 that would be magic bishop see a
bishop e8 there's a page 5 bishop a
bishop c8 bishop what
Age 5 oh sorry and then gain bother him
some so 1 2 3 and then always that - I
didn't even look at that route yeah h5 I
was thinking but g6 is not the square
yeah maybe that's a way to improve this
Bishop and just to get just to keep the
play going we saw this happening with
white in the Sinquefield Cup where I was
able where he was able to do it with the
white side again son
yeah very important idea in French
positions where you reroute the bad
bishop by EA to g6 and h5 I don't play
the French Way opponent gets do that it
against me it's always very groaning
groaning
yeah the guys how is ding Larrin gonna
handle h4 rotate six well the problem is
I see it with rook h6 mary's is I'm
gonna take on e4 and if you take just
for argument's sake with the deep on the
Bishop g7 and if I take with the upon
the same idea Bishop g7 I'm attacking
your rook if you put your rook on g6
then I'll drop back to d4 with the
double threat of capturing on g5 and
capturing on a7 and if you put your rook
on h5 well you may not want to put your
hook on h5 it looks a little bit awkward
there after Bishop f6 and again your f5
pawn could be anima what I think the
other way I just want to always want
these you're doing the same thing Bishop
g7 and then a rib cage fire and now and
now g4 you have with the threat of rook
f5 you have Bishop g5 again and then
like what if I play d4 with the idea of
III I'm just trying but not but why do
you have to do this why don't you just
play for b4 and eventually you play
eight six White has no counter play
white is going to be trying to protect
this position yeah I know I'm trying to
make a winning breakthrough before he
get the fortress you know like d4 and
III just like you can get something
going but it seemed like you were like
basically defending there
so eight six let's go down this line oh
sorry
b4 oh sorry yeah we should I this before
d 4 8 6 H 6 Bishop f4 okay 5
you have to thing so what do you guys
think is this gonna be a draw or a
whimper during rent I think a draw yeah
I'm betting on draw too but it still is
thing going on trying to set up some
traps they are going down our there are
lying I couldn't really see alternatives
though for Magnus I don't want to allow
after this move rook h6 which is by the
way um no it's not hold on just a second
rookie four rook h1 rook h6 not Bishop
c6 rook h6 I don't want to allow rook h3
so I have to play h4 I have no choice
and magnus has played h4 this is
reminding us again of that puzzle we
co-created where you try to take credit
you mean the immortal Sarah won lockdown
people already saw the video so you
can't even pretend we saw this position
I'm going to jump to this kind of
position for example as you described
Ryan White has literally nothing to do
great to break to change the position
but he doesn't have to because black
can't figure out what to do the only
move would be a d4 break which would be
worth sacrificing at some point after
you plays the move h5 for example you've
gotten a whole position on lockdown but
how do you break in as White has no
chances but black has no chance it has
nothing to do to get in again sacrifice
somehow to make a break for this will be
the only one to try to prepare and why
could actually just put a rook on d4
pretty nice and then you have exactly
zero to do so that is what Magnus is
aiming for he's got a bad position and
here comes the king
h4 King d7 on the board
he's trying to hurry up and involve this
king in the act okay so I don't know if
I need to hurry this or not but suppose
I do start with rook takes e4 now are we
capturing how are we recapturing first
of all with the D or the F pawn would
choose one all those lines alone after
Bishop Sheen after this casterman pretty
compelling
we were trying h5 last time okay and
this time instead of my Bishop f6 I see
no reason to hurry play king c3 with the
idea I want to get a blockade and on the
dark squares with King d4 right yeah
that's a good idea I like that idea
stopping any kind of funny business with
d4 and if 85 you just have King d4 but
maybe that's where we need to look 85
King d4 mmm okay I'm feeling good a 308
3 by Magnus he's preparing the long
scale blockade for sure a three Wow I
find that move intriguing I I really you
know I would be a little bit anxious to
put my king on e5 for D for those lines
with B for a for some breakthrough trick
sometimes I wonder about with when your
King was on d4 no g4 on the board that
shuts down the game that's a draw offer
right there mmm-hmm that is a draw offer
I don't think that there's anything now
because the darks were blockade is just
too formidable rook takes e4 finally by
Magnus and I'm sure Magnus saw that move
g4 just probably went okay that's that's
losing with white I don't care if you
are mr. perfect 100% losing with white
and the two game match to start took to
work with the F pond with the F pawn
okay yeah this position shut down I
wonder who will consider this a success
as big Lauren no doubt came into this
position thinking came into the game
thinking a draw is fine I'll take white
next game
Magnus got nothing with the white pieces
and ding Lauren if his attitude is well
I had a whisper of a chance but it
didn't work out so what but now I get
white and Magnus will be on the pressure
will Magnus say yeah I could have been
in trouble there and so I got out of it
or will he think man I just tossed a
white the game completely away and got
zero for it I think that ding is the one
who's going to be the most place because
remind everybody that in the st. Louis
rapid and blitz these players had three
decisive games three decisive games
white won every game
I'd like the white pieces well for the
Ziegfeld Cup what do you think about
this last move by Mathieu for B for
blocking stopping any a5 he has
introduced a second potential weakness
but he probably can defend them both the
pawn on a 3 is now weak and also the
pawn on f2 is weak but he's gonna go
rook d1 or d2 as Jennifer mentioned you
can't play rook f6 so it's gonna take
you a while to play rook f5 say you
start with rook h5 well now I'm in time
rook t1 rotate f5 r up t2 and there's no
you're not breaking through on the Kings
ok 6 was doing around choice and after
rook a6 I've got King b2 just keeping
the a pawn defended me to five and then
rook d1 and then we can just agree to
draw and we expect to draw very shortly
remember unlike in the classical portion
you can offer draw you don't have to
repeat those and I heard Chris Berg me
mention the same thing the draw offers
are permitted and blitz and rapid unlike
the classical where no draw offers were
allowed yeah and here that but you know
I think they're kind of in the half
just doing the repeat and it looks like
this is exactly what's happening as the
first game of the rapid playoff is drawn
now some may say that that's a big
success for doing the rena the ad magnus
in a great position for for doing the
ren and now he gets the white pieces but
keep in mind that Magnus is last victory
in the classical event and his best win
in the Sinquefield cop was that
wonderful game against vaccine with
black exactly Maurice if I could pick
your brain there for a moment because
that was a critical moment after Knight
takes e5 King takes d1 King takes d1 if
you could show that on the board at work
what would have happened if dangler in
had been very ambitious and gone for
this Knight g4 fork gift me upon Bishop
g2 Bishop g2 but should be 77 and now
the most came to see to King to see two
young boys saying
take your pick yep which one do you want
probably gonna cat I'm afraid of Knight
takes b5 the pawns aren't running away
can I cast a long cast along allows
Bishop f4 okay well now I have no choice
I got a take on f2 greed kills a Greek
tonight boo back to g4 h 3 then the
tenderoni on this follows is being
chased backwards yeah yeah so there was
no it wasn't upon sacrifice after all it
it just actually was it was actually it
was 9g for Bishop g2 Bishop b7 king c2
you can take here because b5 Knight
takes Knight takes on b5 looks like this
line is good for block good for black no
after Bishop f4 it's gonna be even ish
even Stephen even ish so ya know this
line is not a real spawn sacrifice it
Wow okay here is our first round
playoffs draw between Magnus Carlsen and
Bing Moran as we go to game 2 with being
with the white pieces and Maurice is
gonna take us through how they got here
they rode at the top yes so we had some
previous transmission problems apologize
for that and we will talk about just how
they got here and let's do it with ding
Lorraine to start we mentioned how great
a tournament he had in the sig field Cup
there were a couple of moments early on
where he was in a bit of danger
certainly round five he played a
brilliant game absolutely brilliant game
against a nice giri such a model game
garry kasparov was impressed magnus
carlsen wasn't pressed on each giri must
have been impressed as well the way he
was taken down and then that round seven
game against Vichy on on man he was in
dire straits and Vichy failed to land a
blow as the glory managed to survive
that one and then in the very next round
round eight he survived would look like
a vicious opening prep by Magnus Carlsen
with beautiful defence on his part saved
the day and then the very next round he
was able to take down Fabio from Yahoo
Caruana in a powerful display of control
and then aggressive chess and he managed
to go to his +2 to end the event on the
other end Magnus Carlsen had a very
different route indeed nine draws in a
row he had not had five draws in a row
in the previous Singh field cups in any
of the ones he had played in but this
one he had nine in a row and with his
back to the wall the world champion
showed what makes him the champ as he
beat Wesley so in round 10 in a game
where Wesley made a couple of mistakes
but hey you've got to make him and then
you got to exploit them and then max Eva
Sheela Grove that was just a brutal
takedown in a wild position where the
Frenchman blades and didn't see the
punches coming as he just simply
destroyed
Maxine vise Sheila grabbing that game
Magnus Carlsen just showing what a boss
he is by winning on a must in a must-win
situation
we did discuss their recent history it
does not look pretty he's 10 1 and wrap
it in the champion showdown and then 6:1
this is back in 2017 Ginga Ren got the
welcome mat really served to him in this
one this a complete wipeout a total of
17 - what kind of number is that but
dinner and showed that hey I do not just
sit back and get punched in the face and
in the rapid two weeks ago the rapid and
blitz jinglin took down Magnus with us
scintillating Queen sacrifice Queen
takes g7 and then hunted down Magnus is
king and made it him Magnus had to
resign before the force mate on the
board they did share one one in blitz
but this is the kind of result that
Chinese fans can say that this is our
boy this is how he plays chess well
again a draw so showing that he can hang
with Magnus
now one game in rapid for it all can't
ding Lauren replicate that magic from
the rapid just two weeks ago
oh well Magnus a time for some sweet
revenge talk about winning on demand
though that back-to-back victory and
again let's just take a look at our
grand chest for 2019 and the road to
London as the top four finishers will
get to the finals Jennifer Magnus
Carlsen has locked up a spot he could
give away some points and still get in
ding the red also looking very good just
needs to get a few points and it for him
like this he is likely to get lots more
maxxium really needs to hope that a lot
of people do poorly in order to get to
London and he has no more events to play
so he's gonna just have to sit back and
watch and hope that the wild car go prep
those want to share with you kids these
guys you wasn't helped yeah I'll be a
second for you back is sending the red
to do well as well because they're
already ahead of that it's exactly
deflate the pool take as many points out
as possible guys and Levon and Wesley
those are true players who have good
chances for a spot but the pressure is
gonna be on as they
play the last two events no question
about it but while I was looking at the
chart I just like staggered by young
neppo if neppo had not just suicided it
himself in the final game how many extra
points he might have only had about nine
no I'm saying he had two tournaments it
was plus three in Zagreb and plus 2 here
plus plus one year
no he's plus two here yes he was plus
two and then lost to literally the guy
was plus three in Zagreb and plus two
here he could easily be in Milan yeah
guaranteed almost he'd almost be
guaranteed to go to London if he had
just done well at the closing in those
instead he just flamed out minus five in
those last rounds from Zagreb adhere and
get 15 points right 1313 is the maximum
that he can 13 know if he's clear from
in the racket and blitz 13 is all you
get 13 clear first rapid which is 13
points oh man so he's a know he will
bypass Maxine so yeah you have a chance
if he gets clear first right that's
that's what I wanted to say problems
with LaVon is still he has to hope they
do badly right or one of one of the two
does bathroom right yes hope for that so
yeah and unfortunately the pamaj nepal
machi did lose most of his chances to
get onto the the tour finals in London
here but he did in hurricane s yes he
had that Greek wasn't here as well
because you know you you wanted to see
their classical battles look a guy who
will get down to the 30-second delay
ASAP and yon who would literally
probably lap him by an hour and a half I
mean it would have been amazing
yeah that would have been a great battle
for you by the way Yann again we needs
to win his next event that's exactly
that's India guess was playing in India
Maggie magnus carlsen swimming in India
as well so he's gonna have to win with
magnets in Deven we've seen we saw
Maggie poorly in the st. Louis rapid and
blitz we are unlikely to see that happen
again
I'm curious is it allowed for magnets to
say you know what I've already locked on
my spot I don't really need to play
India give it to a wild card it's the
first time that the Grantchester is
going to India so I'm sure the fans in
India are just totally thrilled that the
world champion is playing this event
very excited about that the wild cards
get a chance to play again Vicki who
dropped the pen Kalahari Krishna as as
well as the third wild are there other
Indian player but we'll double check on
the K and yeah that's gonna be a great
tournament because skew karo it's also
in India of course yeah a really good
one I can't wait for that one but
another thing that we are really looking
forward today is ultimate moves and it's
starting up in just 30 minutes after the
playoff so probably I mean it really
depends but probably I'd say about one I
do where trash talking is required Ken I
mean this is it's almost like the angels
versus the Devils in this team match I
don't know how I don't know how but
Randy's team got all the good trash
talkers from me
should move on I don't know I mean
somehow in the draft picks he outsmarted
Rex
well Sergei car yeah Kim is on Rex's
team and Sergei and Amish had some words
yesterday on Twitter oh sure
well oh by the way let's just take a
look at the teams first of all we have
team Randy Jennifer team Randy indeed
he's got five beyond oh he curled a
Kimura mission on LaVon Maxime punished
and Yan so bad wait it is a young Randy
I don't see any pieces on that
chessboard by the way where are they
going into the archives to get a pretty
new computerized Barry Magnus I mean
come on yeah bringing down the rating
web circuit can get some some jabs man
yeah so I I think that he was quite
formidable as well
I know Wesley was too nice a guy I mean
a kid oh no no no Wesley comes in with
some sideways sarcasm you know the
Wesley Oh what are you talking about
I've been up in the room with them
wisely does say some snide remarks when
he is all light and goodness I told you
watching him within these ultimate moves
yeah so Wesley likes to get in those
little little jabs obviously it's always
PG PG right not even 13 PG but he gets
in his little jab now and then
absolutely now this is a man by the way
who really really enjoys sitting behind
the white pieces what he has done with
the white pieces in the rapids and blitz
was
amazing and in the sink fill cup what he
did against onigiri and Fabiana car you
wanna with the white pieces was master
class and he accomplished what he wanted
to in game one had a little bit of
chance but managed to draw with high
from your charitable very comfortable
draw said now you got nothing on me
right now I'm the one who can control
and now two views the white pieces and
press a little bit he probably won't
over press go too much he likes to be
solid he likes a small edge and then
show his positional mastery he's not a
wild attacking player but don't put made
in front of him because he will find it
exactly now Magnus on the other hand
sitting behind the black pieces last
time he sat behind the black pieces he
won I mean yesterday yeah versus Maxine
winning on demand with black I mean
manok greater challenge in the world of
chess winning great man with white is
hard enough with black virtually
impossible and to beat the formidable
opponent like Maxine I mean how badly
does Magnus want this title here it is
they both wanted badly Magnus has tasted
the the sweet nectar flowing from the
Sinquefield Cup twice already
ding Lauren never but Magnus wants to
win everything he plays in and ding
Lauren would love to get this for the
first time now Magnus knew coming in
today that the Catalan with g2 g3 is the
bread and butter for ding liran so let's
see what he has prepared and in this
cattle and he just grabbed this pawn on
c4 Jennifer playing for an open cadillac
dealer i need to look for an advantage
somewhere and spending a little bit of
time on the clock when item 3 is the
automatic it's usually just instant
right but he's waiting for check
maybe he was afraid of some early b5
provocative lines he wanted to cross up
Magnus and the Magnus by the way he
didn't like this move Queen a4 check
when he was prepared for Knight up three
then you see Magnus grab a chess piece
that's a towel that we've noticed
recently from him when he grabs a pawn
or anything captured usually it's a
Pawnee take picks up it means he's not
in his absolute comfort zone he's got to
think recalibrate what is what's going
on he just grabs that and he won't move
you see it's in his right hand where my
feeling chips and poker they yeah yeah
right don't put it away as you see there
the chips together that is very
impressive that they can do that so you
see he put the pawn away put the pawn
away and it's like he settled down into
the position but that pawn grab is it's
a bit of uncertainty as about the moment
and then he puts it away he doesn't
leave it in front of him and then move
it's not like he puts it down there he
goes after it again and he's got in his
hand again and I almost never see him
just put it down leave it in front of
him which would seem it like efficient
right but he'll put it away before he
moves what if there are no ponds traded
he's not at the point where he'll take a
queen from the end now here's the point
Queen a4 check guys what is going
through Magnus's mine how is he going to
finally by the way he blocked the check
with the knight Knight on B to d7
followed by obviously a very quick Queen
takes e4 Queen takes e4 recapture and
no.6 looking to harass the Queen and
Bishop e3 normally speaking NEC 5 I was
about to say that black tries to get in
the move c 7c v buy version a KO beyond
that should be three has been played but
that didn't change Magnus is quick
responses you played Bishop d6 each okay
this is definitely not the prep that
Magnus came to the board because you
don't see the combination of Bishop e3
and Knight h3 in the cattle and that is
just a totally different approach
forget crap where's the harmony here for
why
how are we going to harmonize all these
pieces yeah exactly very good question
in fact interesting again as we see
Magnus fidgeting with that pawn ding
Lorraine captured it the black pawn put
it to his right yes and then decided I
don't like it over there picked it up
and put it all the way to his left I've
always put the captured material behind
the clock I just liked it over wherever
the clock was left side right side
didn't matter I thought it was the
polite thing to do it was to not to have
all the pieces I captured of yours right
well also I didn't like to have to when
my opponent took the captured piece and
put them just behind the pieces so you
know you like you're looking at the
board and then you've seen captured
pieces back there just put them away
courteous you sound like you're gonna be
a formidable trash shock or an ultimate
yessir is a trash talker that's for sure
okay what has happened
who's on turn that's why to move again I
blacked I'm sorry Magnus is Magnus is
turn after castles okay well the point
is yeah I'm looking at how am I going to
activate this bishop now what ding
Larrin did by leaving the nut by putting
the knight on h3 he's left this diagonal
open normally speaking with the knight
on f3 the move b5 the queen would move
back Bishop d7 could be played but b5
the Queen moves back and now the rook is
saying yeah we'd have to play work BA
and I don't like that yeah so I'm
thinking Knight d5 maybe trying to move
legs h6 okay that's very common to this
Bishop is not gonna stay on III for the
whole of the game white is going to want
to play E to e for someone so oftentimes
in the catalan you do see Bishop g5
takes f6 h6 is a good waiting move so
let's assume Knight c3 just for now now
the question that I wanted to ask isn't
black obliged at some moment
the movie 6e 5 to get that light square
bishop into the game by the way this
Bishop III move was seen in a big time
matchup with with one Fabiano Caruana
against Vishwanath on anon in Batumi and
that one if I remember correctly was a
smash I think I think probably one in
maybe 26 moves it was a quick one it was
a beautiful win by Fabi I remember it
was a pawn sacrifice it was some kind of
pawn sack wow it is exactly 26 moves I'm
being told good memory there but I
remember because it was impressive 26
move but I remember was a pawn sack it
was like stir this weird pawn sack we're
probably just said yeah I'll just give
you the pawn but my play is just so
amazing and and then he just won and
fishy had to resign he's losing a piece
I remember he lost a piece in that game
- just beautiful tactics by Fabi but
this is Rob this was probably specialty
there but it looks as though block
should be okay in this position and he
has played ding glare and did play
Knight c3 by the way more or less after
a one-minute thing Jen I'm not going to
say yeah too long by the way for what
I'm considering a very off beat Catalan
position both players have been playing
very quickly yeah smart time management
considering it's a rapping game
now again I'm thinking II 6 e v e5 yeah
I like that idea
so what we were gonna do bring our looks
to the song yeah work after you want
rook after you one very common move in
the Catalan Queen e7 getting my queen
off the D file I'm angling by the way I
just want to give you a heads up I'm
playing to play Aoife I'm planning to
play e5 e for to shut down this Bishop
in case you don't take on it but if you
play me for so if you play e4 basically
and I play defy then you have rookie aid
exactly I want to keep the pawn on e5
and p5 was play did not be 5 and this is
now first time we've seen this Queen b3
we be through create a novelty by
Magnusson quickly 9f for bringing that
night into the game you can imagine that
night landing on d3 by the way this one
is sharp Magnus literally has two breaks
to consider big ones at that the move e5
is one a move c5 is the other you might
think about just developing as Bishop as
well to b7 so lots of options for the
world champ to consider meantime digna
reigns moves are sort of easy bring
those rooks over and see what happens
next and you got a world chat about
playing c5 c6 in the position although
right mine doesn't end there because
then you have to calculate c4 Knight
takes the 8 that's why for why we should
be winning 4 right so basically let's
take a look if c5 right away Oh white
moves let's say like work do you want or
something well no I I think you were
right Knights move its if black plays c5
right here
I think that's his game six wins four
right c4
you can't take because then after Queen
takes c6 you're just losing two pawns
when I win the bishop on d6 so you would
have to play c4 to try not to lose
immediately but then in fact you will
lose because Knight takes D a lullaby it
takes on b3 and now knight c6 is exactly
and the night not only gets out but the
night is actually huge beautifully
placed and he's already won upon in a
second on c5 would be wonderful
so Bishop e7 or I would actually be 78
to start the song nice effort to the
shortenings Bishop on 7 yeah just but
here I could imagine that white is
definitely for choice this Catalan with
the night somehow when the night is on
f3 we've seen in Catalans 91 to d3
somehow white has gotten a good cattle
an accelerated somehow I'm not
happy about Magnus's b5 decision to the
computer like it yes it did thinks it's
fine and thinks it's better for blocking
them for black Bishop e7 now saying
equality after takes and takes on b7 so
just equal so just across maybe even a
slight edge for white in this position
but the move d5 is going to be the one
he's concerned about this one here
he's gonna have to pay very careful
attention to black white to play it now
and then black will have to make some
decisions as to what to do as the
dynamism is fast to move e5 runs into
the amazing night east six right anyway
as you have to capture and takes and now
your knight is hanging is an e7 threat
along the long diagonal check so this is
something that he will have to watch out
for his Magnus as this opportunity does
present itself this move with d5 but
we'll see if ding Lauren finds it yeah I
was thinking that d5 he was going to
have to capture maybe on f4 and how
would you judge this one I think blacks
okay c5 or maybe c6 this Bishop on f4
makes a very pleasing and compression I
must say they work I've d1 and yeah on
unbalanced position with a with a
potentially better minor piece but
that's not entirely clear as the Black
Knights don't really have easy home
exactly and here this is like a very
typical cattle and pressure on the Queen
side no normally speaking that's why I
really like this move D he did trade and
he did not go for the d5 position I'd
like the d5 because in a catalan if you
can utilize the half-open c file like if
you could play d5 and the guy can't play
c5 c for you get nice pressure he's
played Knight e3 to stop my D 393 to
stop black from playing C 65 but now
that the LightSquared bishop
can be have been traded c65 1987 was
Magnus's choice he imitated his move by
the way 93 I don't like 85 was the right
way to play because now white doesn't
have any forward motion
well rook c8 and c5 is on blacks agenda
planning to keep quiet
Acy in a straitjacket keep biking a
straitjacket so rooks e1 just trying to
tamp down the play but not playing
solely for too much initiative but that
Queen on e7 oddly it was supposed to go
to a 8 according to the engines every
strange place to go maybe even c8 I
don't think those moves are natural at
all I'm gonna consider them weird well I
think that the idea behind Queen a8 is
also to stop any ideas of night a4 so
you defend the rook that's a classical
move yeah yeah I mean classical game
move is what I need to say 27 is so much
more natural rook AC 1 now the reason I
mentioned that Maurice is that after
rook c8 I do have Knight a 4 I mean
obviously if black ever gets in C 6 C 5
there's gonna be massive trades and it's
gonna be equal but maybe I can play
Knight c4 and I have to Knight a 4 and I
have the timing to play 95 yes you're
right and looks like the rook on b7 has
to resolve itself either maybe just a
retreat of the rook you do not start a
harmonious way to be 8 right unusual
will be 2 double rooks or the beat line
very strange to do don't suspect that's
gonna happen but this one looks more
naturally even if it's somewhere it's
not the best move but it looks much more
natural and preparing to play for c5 in
the position or a 5 rook c8 and then c5
agreed but Magnus has a moment now it's
it's really a moment for him because
actually white is nursing that threat of
9 a 4 could I press a four by the way
and if I can provoke you to play b4 I'm
always happy
my night could end up on the c-4 square
so I'm just wondering rook b7 to b8 a4
b4 night b1 and I'm trying to make a
virtue of the night being on d3 in the
sense that a trade on a4 you can't
capture b2 but are you threatening to
take on b5 at all I don't know yeah
scary thing to do the retreating mer of
b7 b8
the rook on b7 made a woeful impression
so Magnus just restoring the harmony in
his position for now with a move rook b8
gen how do you feel this opening has
gone is then going to be happy with the
outcome well he's up about 5 minutes on
the clock
it's important that's important quiet it
doesn't seem like he has some kind of
big advantage either I think there's a
high chance that they're gonna go to
blitz not that this game is drawn or
anything like there are lots of play it
wants to play remaining but I still feel
like both players are just playing so
well in this game work do you want
played yeah and again I think that now
it's time to abandon the ranges he got
up from the board because we only have
25 minutes yeah
every minute counts he's up Magnus is
not no fool he's gonna make a quick move
he wants to make a quick move to exploit
the moment well I was gonna say I think
it's time to abandon any ideas of e6000
for rook F a to c8 what you play and
preparing that c7 c5 break which again
as we've mentioned if we can trade off
all of the the bits on the c5 score then
it's a very easy draw clock running
[ __ ] Lauren and he's not at the table
and a sighting he might have gonna hit
the restroom but we have compassion
booth had to come and say hi mom hi
dad sorry I haven't called I've been a
bit busy
good just wanted to say no no we say in
confession yeah yeah Betty and that ding
went to the confession and just taking
the opportunity to make a Skype call
home here he comes
wonder what his feeling is as he had to
rush back to the board and realize a
move was played he glanced over the
clock quickly there it did not take him
a minute though he took him less than a
minute after the move was played and get
back to the board and again and reset
himself remind everybody it's a
10-second delay
that's right question is how does it
ding Ren try to keep an advantage I
would see five coming that's the problem
I don't see anything beside the move a
four to tried to create right now
there's these pawns are not weak unless
they can be attacked and I'm thinking
that after a 4 C 5 they'll be wholesale
trades on the c5 square then you're
trying to create a weakness on the B Phi
pawn with a 5 beat takes if I have a 4
takes b5 if you don't do that what else
are you gonna do I mean c5 you're not
playing f3 and Bishop F 2 and E 4 it's
gonna take you forever and this a this
one looks so drawn this one just look
the symmetry in the lawn structure well
let's try it
harmony in both sides camp so a for c5
right more or less what else is looking
around this is not to draw written all
over it takes well is it we've seen I
want to say ding Larenz but spending
some really wondrous play with the white
side Queen B form can I make an argument
for a slight edge
why not why be threatening something but
it's gone on before b5 is a weaker than
the positive b7 wait Knight d5 is a
trick well 95 is a threat if you'd well
there's a rook takes you getting little
sweet see 795 was a threat but now he
looks yeah looks ok yeah
Queen f4 mm-hmm you ever lie queen at 4
mmm I'm taking it and again if I had a
rook on before maybe I could make some
kind of claims hmm well as a cattle and
player myself do feel that White's a
little bit better at those positions
again I agree it's very very slight a
modal back down
oh man that's that really is not going
to bring any kind of edge a3 well c5 no
choice I mean I mean c5 what do you
think Jen do you think that maybe night
before but after c5 you can't play that
so yeah I got a I got a stop night
before and well I no choice and there it
is Knight takes e5 is now on the board
we're expecting a wholesale trade Bishop
takes e5 Bishop takes e5 all this has
been played
ok this now by the way I think that
darks were a bishop is a is a very good
Bishop I think it's time you you take
that Bishop Knight takes e5 oh yeah
don't they should play exactly and d6
ordinary 6 yeah you you pretty much got
to take that know to open to let me have
exactly what takes d5 played rook takes
e5 now ok Dingley remember against
Fabiano he had doubled on the C file and
Fabiano had doubled on the D file 982 no
is in really draw mode right now
it's incredible watching a teaching
standpoint he's trying to go night
before threatening the a6 pausing
squared that's not gonna hurt that's not
gonna hurt no because you can also just
go Knight d5 here right and then ninety
five is gonna provoke e4 I'm not gonna
let that okay or by the way I may be
Dylan Dingle Aaron is thinking rook
takes e5 Queen takes e5 rook c1 and
grabbing for example 95 right grabbing
that the C file could actually no this
is a man who's gonna do your e for idea
looks I mean I don't know if it's gonna
be amazing six and then I actually
attack your pawn you do indeed and I
don't know if I should defend it or try
and Magnus is reaching and he's played
a5 which by the way is a very good movie
in the night from coming to be ever
getting to be four is ruled out with it
by this turn and Queen before ideas as
well although it was pretty clear that
wasn't on the agenda Knight a two so
let's imagine take stakes and rook c1 I
think the C file is actually you there
are more the the business squares of c7
and c6 are weaker than d7 and d6 so let
me grab it is yes sir this is Magnus is
playing to win now
well Queen e5 Queen time five Queenie
five yeah right and then a nice little
rook d8 nice little 94 I mean I don't
see why black well I'm not sure I agreed
with night what I'm saying is my thing I
can squeeze a little something okay he's
not I'm not saying he's better than what
I'm saying he's starting to think you
have done nothing with the white pieces
so long I just held you back
you've been playing passively that night
three thing you allowed this a three
move Ubaid 83 so you and I can go to a
two I just shut that down what are you
doing I think your mindset is wrong you
should be trying to beat me
hey if you want to just play like this
then gladly I will take you into this
country and don't mess up again start
playing the proper defensive moves your
queen c3 for example is an interesting
move but what if he takes on e to their
queen take C to when we takes a five is
not possible because of queen tob - no i
exploiting the we have different
positions I'm starting you're thinking
about Queenie I started with rook c5
queen c5 queen c3 mine I'm thinking why
tonight on a queen three was digging
around choice night now this move seems
more solid maybe he's gonna reconfigure
things and put his knight back on c3 now
that he's like looking at the e4 square
right yeah rook takes t1 was Magnus's
choice and now Knight takes you one
trying to bring back the caliber into
the game exactly what night on a two was
really sad to say the least I'm not sure
I would have chosen that move by Magnus
at night
rook C 191 the engines actually like to
sharp rook f5 which seemed why that's
very very counterintuitive give up Sarah
just a threaten Knight g4 but okay
that's an in that one that would have
been a wild one and not but rook see one
night c1 and somehow I feel that why
does that scary moment that you were
kind of mentioning his past because
White's Knight ready to go to the d3
square and again Catalan
players like bingler in who are so
experienced in these endings will will
feel that they they stand well yeah this
one looks like there's a high chances
guys they're going to blitz which is
gonna be no question about it feels like
this is going it just has more draw
written on it
whenever you get number one versus
number two or number one versus number
three you got to be excited about
watching them play to 2800 players 320
800 players on the planet I mean they
play so well and rapid that it you do
get a lot of drugs but when you take it
to blitz the chances of something crazy
happening crazy tactics are so high
so definitely guys you're gonna want to
stick with us is it looks like this
match high likelihood of going to blitz
big lauren winning one of the blitz
games they played with the white piece
his antagonist winning with white
himself so this this could be going back
and forth this they swing those blows
and those punches both of them right now
clearly playing well and it looks as
though big Lauren is saying I'm not
gonna go for anything special against
you but beat me right
can you beat me but it will come if this
goes on it will go to an Armageddon
eventually yes it's up to arbiter
discretion so they could just mandate
more but more blitz I can get a little
bit
I think it'll depend a little bit on the
schedule and the timing so yes if
undecided after three blitz matches so
three pairs of blitz game six games
you're saying yeah yeah but it's not
like but each is an individual mini
match right so you don't get to play all
six right you lose Game four so but if
all the mini blitz matches are drawn
then it'll be chief arbiters discretion
and yes good chances I think that will
end up being an Armageddon
after all of those mini matches and
blitz and are completed and that said
we're only not even an hour and a half
into the day because of these chores
they're their first draw and this one
they could offer a draw at any point and
maybe maybe that one will be saving time
as well we'll have plenty of time to say
let's play blitz let's play blitz let's
let's play some more blitz and more
blitz if it gets to that instead of
doing an Armageddon which I think most
people would rather not see for a draw
to win for black after so much of a
strong they might decide to play more
blitz games totally as you're right a
lot of it will depend on the timing as
these games are
going by perhaps quicker than we
expected it's more a little ahead of
schedule but what's interesting to me is
who is it good for it to go to blitz
because it on one hand Carlson's edge
and rapid has historically been even
greater than his engine blitz right the
highest rate of player you know by so
many points whereas a blitz the margin
of difference between him and Bingley
Ryan is quite narrow and we just saw
that in the st. Louis Magnus lost his
number one blitz ranking in the world
one of the things that happen in saying
yeah yeah one of the things that
happened in that st. Louis blitz who are
the winners who won the Blitz ok car
yakin and ding Moran and you got cheated
to say I believe all three of them that
ding leran acquitted himself rather
nicely when he fix the Blitz points did
ding Loren but that said when I asked
magnets in the interview yesterday what
would he prefer game 25 or game 10 says
game 10 sounds more fun whoa something
like that
this is a man magnus carlsen who just
loves a challenge and if he's going to
play somebody blitz he wants to play
Hikaru Nakamura yes the greatest blitz
of player but here's a question as
Magnus ever not won a rapid tiebreak oh
really
you mean he's never had to take at the
Blitz huh that's interesting the World
Championship match he took darn cognac
in in rats right in the world on fabi
I know I remember a wrap a tie breaker
for vikon's a against onigiri that
Magnus won and the rapid they didn't
have to go that's what I'm saying Magnus
not win the rapid could dig Lawrence a
mini success if we go to the World
Championship which I plan to do I'm
hardly qualified by rating and I ever
win the care that it's don't think
you're taking me down in the rapid
portion and I can show you that I can
beat you in blitz so maybe this is a
minor success for him to say if I want
to make draw I can make draw against you
you're not changing much here impressing
me that much
the past is the past yeah you know to
the eyes of a lot of chess amateurs
they'll take a look at this position and
say draw and I think for a lot of the
computer engines to those it's gonna say
draw and so on but I've seen so many
chess grandmasters like Paul Anderson
like Zoltan really like Anatoly Karpov
really appreciate this night on d3 which
is on the one hand defending b2 and many
times when you get a position like Queen
a7 rook c7 that night on d3 can suddenly
pivot and play 95 as ding Lauren showed
in his game with fabbi that 95 in that
f7 pawn can really become a challenge so
even though you know we are anticipating
that this games going to be a draw
ding Lauren is not unhappy about this Oh
No and that's AG Ben wait your quick
answer when does Magnus Carlsen lose
usually quick answer why does he
normally lose over optimistic over
optimism exactly you've seen all the
time he presses too much so he'll take a
position that might be equal and say no
no I don't play for drawers
so if ding Lorraine can say I'm blocking
you I'm blocking you keep trying stupid
stuff and ok that's ok and then you make
a mistake by pressing too much that's
when he usually loses because he doesn't
like to just play a position that's just
drawn and leave it alone so you see
there ding Lauren just taking small
steps forward but Magnus looking to
neutralize that Queen on e4 the point is
if the queen is not protecting the e5
square and we get a chance to play like
night before and disallow your whole 95
idea exactly I think that this 95 is a
good one but rook c5 right now okay and
it's starting to have shades of that
Fabi game a little bit
rook c5
my plate or rook c5 I like it
idea Queen c4 tickles we wrote night you
know I don't even know what happens if
night before guys night before Kennedy's
trying to stop you at 95 95 exactly this
is really taking on shades of that game
that he beat Fabiano and his pieces are
better than blocks right now
that's right now if 92 I guess
be careful rook c8 is yeah we see 8 is
always in the positions always in the
position watch everything 8 7 and you
add a little queen d3 and thank you very
much for your night mm-hmm
be very careful this is turning a little
bit after that rook c5 move it's not not
better like clearly better for white but
starting to trend in that direction
exactly well here I mean again Magnus
the Brooklands
on b8 versus the rook on c5 the rook on
b8 hinting B to that that B to pawn is
so well defended by the knight that it's
actually white rook that that has more
option more opportunity Queen c4 e for
rook C 795 you can easily see ding
Lorenzo's not so easy to see
Magnus should we just be playing the
greed magazine the game is turned rook
c7 be careful what's a check you want to
allow d8 so that we need to be okay wait
by the way there is a queen d1 check so
that so you can't just snap on a5 right
the FI pawn so staying active is madness
so Magnus is eyeing Queen d1 check going
after the e 2.7 minutes behind oh and
the clock is Magnus Carlsen a change you
to quickly played by to chill move here
by being run right now the question is
do we go queenie one trying to stay as
active as possible or include a four
with the idea of a three just get rid of
all the pawns on the queenside
does night before liquidate things now
that you don't have Roxy eight why would
you want to provoke my Knight to e5 no
yeah that's probably not a good idea
95 94 95 my knight jumps to the
sideboard
I have Knight a six and I'm attacking B
- wow really going after the bar
your knight went from D 5 to a 6 I am
buck c6 I don't think you're actually
winning a pawn no we're just looking a
Jennifer is a little bit worried about
Magnus by ding Lauren's
nice controlling and you just kind of
like you you pushed your knight from
default a knight C 2 instead that maybe
that would see to Magnus showing some
uncertainty there as he's 8 minutes down
is it 8 yes 8 minutes down on the clock
looking to play a 4 on that move and
then he hesitated as he realizes that he
is the one who's being pressed here he
does have a queen b7 idea I was tickling
that King what f3 is standard but f3
could happen we see you 3 square is a
little weak right
but f3 those are you know I've seen
there's there's an e4 by the way that
you also have to watch out for that
efore move by white and white is going
downhill
I mean downhill in yeah so Sarah wants
to know just gaining momentum as we
speak like a snowball going downhill and
Magnus has to watch out for this efore
shot that could cause real issues in its
position whose pieces do you like better
oh why why is fully centralized yeah
well especially when you get tonight
into e5 and I'm really nervous about
that I guess it's just shadows of that
Bobby game
Magnusson getting some play it after
after intimating that he wanted to play
a for he you spent a little time and
chose instead to put the Queen on b7
threatening discover check a darning
minute
yeah threatening me encouraging f3 yes I
would say encouraging f3 as well
well ding Lauren with that big and edge
on the clock can spend two minutes and
decide what to do and he has played
three not taking any time to decide that
does have its own weaknesses by the way
because it does open up that second
ranked slightly yeah and you can put a
king on f2 and work wait a key to it's
now gonna come with a check so yeah
there's definitely some minuses lady not
only the e3 square well I played six
queen Isaac's was actually played
quickly by Magnus and now 95 is no
longer on top because Queen takes a e2
with a check but that 85 is hanging
between a six was played right ended the
pawn as well it seems like a good idea
but I mean from all my experience
watching these great players of the past
f3 and King f2 very very traditionally
played voluntarily it's not like in this
particular case Queen b7 provoked f3 a
lot of cattle and players will
voluntarily play even f4 and King at 3
as well playing for endgame there's a
Shireen a4 as well in this position by
the way King f2 is kind of an automatic
move yes can we get can we get active to
b3 what just so we know Queen a4 just
for a second please
I mean a for what do you do about your a
pond can you have to was played by the
way though right
I mean what do you do you it looks like
you have to play rook aids well anything
that puts me on the defensive
makes me think about who can I go for
but England played but if I can get to
instead so you might have missed a
moment right there with Queen a for a
bit more song with the idea that now
with 95 we we get counter play with work
III so I'm thinking
b3 and 85 rookie three and luckily my
queen on a six depends the the c8 square
okay and if I go queen a4 is still back
in business how do you guard all this
maurices idea of Queen a for you're
going to have to sacrifice an exchange
or resign so eighth were playing by
Magnus that he might have missed for
ding Lorraine and now Magnus takes
advantage of that and puts his paw no
need for removing the weakness you are
you sure your queen c4 I'm trying to
encourage a trade of Queen so I can get
that cattle and ending I've been
discussing the Queen a7 pinning you on
is a seven-way 787 rook D farm no this
pin there's a Oh queasy for is what you
play sorry yeah yeah a 4.87 look-see for
I think it's provoking a3 isn't it and
you could go okay for but then I could
take up the Queen upon not it was just a
trade it's a heads-up trade of the eight
phones Jennifer he missed one day for he
miss queeny for a long time he missed a
moment King f2 i that's the movie
playing blitz all a tempo the Queen a
for you fine in the classical game
that's right you blow the guy down make
him it a bit more passive by the way
with the move okay
now dig Lauren playing Queen c4 and
shutting stuff down Magnus looking quite
confident after getting in the move a
for and again Magnus is the one down on
the clock right Jen yes I mean wonders
you know he wanted to play a for earlier
so that could have been a little bit of
a clue to take around that he was trying
to shut down those possibilities right
and quiet 87 not
yeah I wanted to trade off over draws
queen a7 queen deviously queen a6 as a
repetition is on top but yeah that's
funny that that that could have been the
way for doing the rent to realize Magnus
was worried about we made four because
he yes he intimated that he wanted to
play a four earlier exactly they kind of
kind of helping your opponent there
discovered the move that maybe he'd
missed important note though that moment
when he repeated doesn't mean that big
Lauren wants a draw but he might want
information does Magnus want the draw
yes now he knows yeah now you know Agnes
is willing to repeat so now he just has
to spend some time because he could play
Queen C for if he wants to after maybe a
couple of minutes if he can't find
anything better then he can just play
Queen C four and get his business going
and get his drawer so he will look now
but Magnus has given him information any
bit of information you can get a chess
game good idea
and Magnus is down to five twenty-nine
if only Bing Lorraine could have
squeezed a little bit more juice here to
cause problems for Magnus it would have
been would have been nice he could've
get maybe at the three minutes he could
have gotten into but by allowing that a
four move it just looks like the week
the main weakness and blacks position is
gone and his King is defensible your
King has a little bit of exposure
you better be accurate from this moment
forward if you're gonna try to put the
pressure on Magnus
well I think this is a great practical
decision for jingler n though you know I
just this idea of offering as more you
said the repetition and now taking its
time deciding what else besides Queen C
4 is on h4 h4 h5 and trying to make it
difficult so there's an eighth rank the
problem as I see is the desirable h4 is
that even if I do get in my know and
there it is a handshake as we go to
blitz Tingler inverse Magnus Carlsen is
it's gonna get faster and faster here
both men playing so perfectly so far
well I want to say these are two very
high-quality rapid chess games as they
go to the blitzen can you remind our
viewers including myself what are the
format for the blitz games Chen well
it's game five with a three second delay
if I recall correctly and yet there it
is game five with three second delay if
those games are undecided after three
matches then we either do more blitz or
go to Armageddon or something bad the
chief are better thought out that I did
it but that's kind of any matches of two
thousand unlikely scenario they're not
gonna play six games they're gonna play
a pair of game well they might play six
right but only if the first two mini
matches are thirteen split by the way by
the way we did see an epic many epic
match between two of the competitors who
are here shocker Madeira versus versus
Mac Simba Shilla Grove in the Grand Prix
series in Riga yes they went to the
finals
they drew mmm did they draw the first
three games I believe they drew the
first two games but nevertheless they
were tied after rapid they were tied
after the first mini match in blitz they
were tied after the next mini match it
blitz they were tied after the third
Biddy Manson blitz and it went to the
Armageddon game which with which chakra
are one with the black pieces when he
had drop and he had draw adds in fact
but he won and then he won the title so
we have already seen this happen this
year between two of the best in chess
and we get to see this man
will it happen yet again this is as
exciting as a guess you get the best
players swinging at each other and can't
get in can't get in and this could go on
for a while folks well we're gonna take
a very short break because we're not
expecting too much time between the
rapid and the Blitz but we'll be back on
the other side of this break do we know
what's coming up on break anything
special fireside chats okay so on to the
restroom real quick and better you'll
miss it quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back at the 2019 Sinquefield
cup where we are going to shortly crown
a victor as zingaran and magnus carlsen
now move on to blitz and look at dingle
around trying to get into the zone as he
now gets the white pieces to kick off
the action - very well played rapid
games especially a game one I think of
the story that Robert Byrne told me
about Tigran Petrosian that guy was so
good he was playing a defensive
combination before I realized I had an
advantage
play the defensive combination with 96
giving up a pawn to get a bishops of
opposite color position Dean might have
had something in Game one Magnus
neutralized it and came to a good draw
Maurice what do you see in this matchup
a blitz
I see Diggler in should feel comfortable
that he was able to press Magnus in both
games but I also see a little bit of
hesitation on his part because he he had
his chances to be more aggressive but it
looks like he's being very contained
instead of going for the more sharp
lines against Magnus but at the moment
Magnus has to feel like I got to beat
this guy so far so solid let's see
whether not he can keep up the pace
Magnus has said famously I think faster
time controls favor the more talented
players and I think he believes that
he's the most talented one of the bunch
as natural moves come so easily to him
when he's playing in flow then he can be
extremely dangerous
he misses nothing but will that be the
magnets that shows up for these two
games or will it be the one that showed
up for the sailors rapid in blitz where
he was not in flow at all so far though
you got to say high level definitely
high level chess from both sides this
one though will there will be mistakes
don't blink
there'll be mistakes the question is who
catches what as the seconds tick down I
have a second reason Magnus wanted this
to go to blitz he could get his number
one what's ranking bad goodie really
only a few points away from Hikaru
Nakamura this time in English move order
to perhaps get into a Catalan sorry
Jenna I just really wanted to ask you
this question how historic would it be
if a ding Liron would to make an upset
of the world champion right here and now
wow it would be an awesome upset as it
would give us a brand new sing field Cup
champion meaning it every soul vector
would be independent right we'd have
we'd have never had to sole victors
where is right
magna Sweeney would also be historically
mean that he'd won three of the seven
Sinquefield cups lost the tie breaks oh
yeah all that would cut me to play now
he's not won in the rapid portion which
is already a big bit of news we'll see
right now they're in that Catalan ish
but no longer true Catalan the pawn will
not get to d4 with ease as c5 has
already been put on the board right in
this particular version however white
usually aims for moves like a four and
night a three to c4 but Dingley room
very quickly put his Knight to c3 I find
that a bit puzzling I would expect
Bishop e7 followed by quickly castles
rook e8 and b5 and that's a very well
known way for black of making equality
from White's point of view White's
looking to play for us with castles and
D to d4 well again Singhal area and one
of the most experienced cattle and
players one of the things that Magnus
might do is really change the entire
character of the struggle by playing for
a 6 e 5 a kind of a reverse Morosi bind
if you will to shut down White's
attempts to get in D to d4 and that's a
very very different game we'll see what
Magnus a big tank for a blitz wait for a
blitz get out of rapid mode gettin out
of rapid mode and get into blitz mode
where your move your moves have to flow
this is a long time to be thinking
already
down to 2:30 2:30 and Chetan sorry 3:30
3:30 on an opening that's extraordinary
remember the word I used before in
Magnus's favourite word flow yeah he
wants to get in flow we that's that deep
think is not a flow type move it's up to
I think didn't written right now should
just move like next move
Castle get his cash yeah just get it out
it's not rapid Magnus's long think could
somehow get you into the feeling that
you have to think long as well both of
them both of them would get into that
rapid get inside that rapid thing it's
like a g4 I was just going to say I'm
not a big fan of this move Queen c7 d4
the most attractive moved to my eyes
because you know the best thing to do
develop with gain of tempo and Bishop f4
natured on d4 and now Bishop c5 quickly
playing takes Knight takes Bishop c5
might be three I must say I'm really
double guessing a lot of Magnus's moose
and Knight be three there's by the way
because Bishop f4 was on White's agenda
Bishop d6 and then castles castles but
what if the bishop doing on d6 yes
waiting on granite yeah well look day
one and suddenly d1 rights are beginning
to emerge on that D file the bishop on
g2 is fantastic it's hard to unleash
this was the the pieces unravel I should
say the pieces for black Magnus has now
taken two pawns he's fiddling with at
the moment 250 toad England 419 on the
clock and White's better no question
well rookie one again eyeballing this
Bishop on d6 and if he could and he's
forced the bishop to move Magnus how
many times right zoom in 365 shame three
instantly play he's trying to keep that
edge in the clocks are you doing it
moves too
developing his pieces ready to play rook
c1 yes Knight a4 so hard to unravel your
pieces here you can't play b5 because of
the pain work c1 is ready to come into
the decision right away is this Bishop
on g2 really stopping the natural b5
Bishop d7 for black Magnus these big
drum biggest problem right now badly now
for example if you play rook b8 one of
the things that white might do is simply
play Bishop a7 force the rook back to b8
then play Bishop to d4 and leaving black
to try to find a scheme of development
as you've been talking Magnus still has
much time you've spent just discussing
it and he spent yet another minute and
he's now under the two-minute mark under
the 140 mark yet now Magnus is in real
trouble he knows it and he can't figure
out what to do right now and he looks
frozen absolutely frozen in the position
Magnus grown almost three minutes in a
worse position I think it's time to come
up with one of those really splendid
defensive combinations maybe Bishop
takes c3 finally 95 I was about to say
95 with Bishop c3 but he played 95 at
once please saying okay take my pawn
bishop takes d5 magnus saying ok now I
can see a way to development Knight f6
Bishop h3 doubtlessly oh no there's a
Bishop c5 nasty shot in the position
right here right now right now Bishop c5
blocky love it the line on the C file so
you could take 95 with tempo you can't
take 95 not because your Queens hanging
clear by playing Bishop c5 when Knight
takes the knight takes on d5 and I can
show it on the board here Bishop to c5
and if Knight takes but not me my lady
Knight d5 look at this crushing position
he would have had and then the pawn just
drops he would have had it would have
been
big trouble for Magnus right here but he
did not see it miss he just developed
his rook instead fine and II where
Magnus is going under one minute but and
I think this is what Magnus needs to now
play the move Knight f6 that Knight
takes d5 Queen take c2 rook takes c2
Bishop f5 he gets to finally develop his
mute item at the mere cost of a pawn yes
deal at the moment it was a great great
success for Magnus to bail out here and
actually he's gonna win his pawn back
instant oh no no he doesn't win his pawn
back instantly I beg your pardon
he still has to play Bishop well no I
can't why did he sue Queen T now the
bishop is hanging in must move who he
magnus really gave because he could have
done this much better than this right
now okay didn't look possible but here
comes Knight e5 we will look at it later
right now a full pawn and that night on
c5 looks beautifully placed as well now
that Bishop on CA that's going to be the
only compensation that black has and
he's gonna have to prove himself as rook
e8 have been played there he goes to try
to trick ol Bishop takes Knight scumming
Bishop takes Knight we just saw this
happened exactly you saw this exact
thing happened Agnes Getty that you
can't let the light square Bishop leap
into the game so five rookie five rookie
5 f6 rookie 3 king of seven he's played
started he's been f6 and king f7 and
black is actually making progress
thankfully for him he's getting his King
off the back right f5 tempo right now
right here right now f7 into the game
with a queen and he's got 25 seconds
left he needs to put that piece away and
he did go for Bishop a fight
originally he was reaching for his King
Jenn I thought it we were gonna say King
at 7:00 but he's played Bishop f5
there's a knight d3 opportunity though
now 93 and don't give him this piece at
all cause he fine so stop being vicious
stopping Bishop c5 allow this pin but
leave your extra pawn on the board and
but you know I got to say the two
bishops is going to be a compensation
definitely we're clear on that
but it's worse if you let him trade
Bishop takes Knight agree that's
something you don't want on the board at
all at least stay up least a up a pawn
with the knight on the board by the way
this is remarkable dad did not play it
one more chance to play Bishop takes on
c5 and this get to pardon me
I hate bishops of opposite color
position where I'm pretty sure I can
save myself
rook Tereus missed by jingler intimate
rook see a magnus now in terms of making
a draw yes he's eyeballing rook c2 for
play it's stopping that stop rook see -
but now he gets to trade upon on the
side there
I just wish for ding lorenz sake he had
a little bit more juice in this position
because it's not that easy to make moves
with the three-second delay we've seen
it before it's very tough
pushing that reveal I've get that pawn
to h5 king f7 all right now you just
hang w passed upon though I mean no
you're not gonna get a passed he prone
ago Bishop e6 Bishop c4 plant my pawn on
d5 and well he did it actually at a
different way when he beef i first plant
the bishop on c4 and then say you don't
get a passed pawn you don't get to play
e4 e5 e6 why can't anybody for
and therefore and I mean you won't get
to put the pond anything oh never never
what about a pawn on f5 can I get that
and make you worry well if you can throw
in f5 and rook f8 mate I would be
worried Spenny for Bishop c4 and now
I've got rook D to check and III
harassing wasn't that afraid what's this
g5 check what is he doing
chief I'd check he's trying to bar eggs
he's really marching into the position
okay seven check is a problem but this
that was weird Magnus played rook d3
right away he could have played g5 damn
it by rook d3 did not calculate the
ramification so played work back to d7
stopping work a7 14 seconds right now
for Magnus but doing red also going
underneath a minute king g6 whoa on the
attack and Magnus has to think about
this there's nothing to think about he's
got it take it's an h5 a matin to blow
no no you got to go King f7 King e6
mm-hmm correct
king of 17 e6 don't go Bishop e6 good
advice yet 10 seconds total time for
Magnus right now Oh G 5 or 5 oh this is
looking like progress for ding Lorenzo
right of mate forces rook F a rook d5
check and here comes g5 rook to the 8th
so you can check from behind King e6
another Jeff 7 what is the purpose here
on East 7 instead of f8 that makes sense
well the change is mine and now going
forward that G pawn
looks vulnerable they should see the
king from mommy did you say no King g6
for you another check and now he's
backing up got a good bite no Bishop d4
on top right now how does the bishop get
to play a target now hitting the pawn
jack driving White's came back so we all
have
d 3 to defend but g5 and a g6 sighting
g6 rook da to stop making progress here
now don't allow Bishop D forever how
does he get his Bishop to this diagonal
that's the whole point
white desperately needs to put his
bishop on the a1
he needs to hit g7 and to bring the king
up King in right that's the first step
check get back to deal with the mate and
now you couldn't take the pawn on h5
because of Ruby 8 mate what about a rook
what about rook to e7 so you can play
King to D oh no he's King at five
doesn't do it whoa he did it with
tactics he just did it because a maid
problem Bishop d6 a ship d6 was a sweet
move and he could still leave it there
he's looking at this line is that the
back rank Mays fine Bishop e5 I'll do it
immediately but why didn't he go King g5
I don't know rook takes a skate now King
g5 now trouble right now oh he can't go
back because of rookie 7 right but he
couldn't go back because but who's gonna
stop the Jeep on
well that's Bishop here comes the King
or Bishop c4 to say it looked almost
like me oh how does he stop this yes it
still feels like it's but now he's
getting his room behind the G pawns
let's look this is winning completely at
the moment this he missed a big win did
Diggler in but both sides now with no
time on the clock already with only 10
seconds
oh no why did he play King to D king ban
here he goes another check forcing the
king over he must be winning directly
here but 5 seconds left or I'm not sure
then Magnus hesitating you can't take a
second why is it repeating is ding
Lauren if you why not just check and now
we're waiting we'll release the king
then 3 seconds for Magnus two seconds
now back to 5 and the check now another
check does another check if a rook
to see oh man your next move five
seconds four magnets okay there would be
a three-second oh we didn't go for the
three move repetition with rookie to
another check driving the nollie seven
now the king is stuck but how do you get
your Jeep on forward precisely and
Magnus could even think about rugby - no
he's just gonna breathe look defensive
they're fighting with just nine total
nine seconds five seconds total I think
it's gonna be a draw guys but why why
does it just move his bishop now moving
his check going back again there now
this looks like a meeting repeat okay
now Bishop back to d4 it should not want
to draw he is torturing Magnus right now
to find the right moves Magnus down so
once my guess is lost my time Magnus has
lost all time ding the rim pushing him
over Wow those one minute two minute
things that Magnus took early in the
opening costly Jennifer Wow the jacket
is now he has to come back to even up
the score just to stay alive in the
battle for the Sinquefield Cup title
being Iran and that that was almost was
it four dings time I think ding Lauren
also only three seconds more than the
Meghnath he was at about nine seconds
based I'm wrong but still I mean that
what he had no time to think so he was
repeating I was a little worried for him
that he was repeating the position
though he probably did I but there was
no time to claim yeah well let's just
take a look at how he lost that time
because it was like he's just losing
that one half seconds and he needs to
play King d7 quickly he was doing so
fantastically for so long hanging on in
this position and we're ignoring he was
just throwing the King the bishop upon
and the rook at him but eventually
something happened around here you might
have made a claim and I guess
ding wouldn't and Merritt was it was
that rookie form of where he was just
about to me I it's surprising it looked
like he was about to hit the clock on
time but somehow the second passed
faster than he thought it did
Wow that was shocking and I think for
the first time in his career Magnus is
behind in a tiebreaker we were look
talking about his tie breakers coming in
and mostly he's won them in Rapids never
having to really go into the blitz but
now ding lair in all he needs is a draw
with the black pieces to win the sync
field Cup and he showed something there
in that little edge we saw he could have
he sort of did repeat but we were saying
it looks like a repetition but he had
more time and when you're in that
situation you are obliged to go for it
you have an edge in a blitz situation
you can't and you're up upon you can't
say let me repeat repeat you have to
calm yourself down and deal with the
tension and say I'm gonna play different
moves and see if you can keep up the
defense because once you put a different
move your opponent has to think is there
a threat what's happening I'm in trouble
and just that hesitation wins the game
you have to go for it and that was a
sign there for ding Laurent as he went
for it in a critical situation and got
the game that's how you do it as a
chance was he winning in the final
position he has position but he was
winning before that he was just winning
before this is the moment that well it
wasn't one kind of thing that you could
technically I do technically see in an
instant I will show you
you heard my producer say he'll show it
to us live but I can show you this
moment here this is where he lost this
time but we were looking where did ding
glare in mr. win and they're okay now
after King D 6 there's a roof g4 coming
up which will be
the losing move in terms of the clock I
think it's trying to show us a win on
the board for King Moran which isn't
there but this is where Magnus after
Bishop to d4 stopped right here after
keeping hanging tight for dozens of
moves yes it seems like right now he
froze for some reason right as our
screen is also frozen he's going for
rook g4 and he looks he's his arm is
covering the clock making for Mac
suspense but no he doesn't make it he
doesn't make it by just what is it maybe
a millisecond yes this is now it's all
about yeah little bit too long with the
rook yeah is this wanted to show you
Magnus yeah but seriously that was a
very hard defense by the way it's not
easy to play when you thought I was
lacking shocking that he lasted that one
he really was a great defense we've seen
other people get down to the three
second increment in a defensive position
and three second delay not increment and
it seems almost impossible because just
physically making the move is hard let
alone also thinking exactly the final
position look closer to a draw that'll
win to me but Maurice you said that was
a missed opportunity earlier in the game
yes right here for
I ran as we see the current scores a
leave for him right here for ding Lauren
he has a clean win
well clean a winning position with
Bishop to f6 now in line is so what are
you gonna do about this check which wins
your Bishop okay that's gonna I have to
check you I guess well check is probably
the most aggressive this one runs into
rook eight seven with a mate threat row
and you could feel the trouble there
that's a big deal and then he's gonna
drive you out and just push his pawn so
that one is a problem so Bishop f6 you
do have to check the King moves and now
there's still the check threat right you
could chase the King with this move yes
you could chase the King with this move
and now again there's the check threat
and he's pushing this check thread he's
unstoppable and he's gonna push her King
that way and then he's threatening some
recovery so you have big problems in
this position yesterday this was a lot
of winning Bishop here was was tight and
that would have caused real problems for
Magnus and they were and missed it of
course they were both in time pressure
and played kf6 in that position and the
game turned and allowed Magnus to
restart his defensive setup it's
remarkable that a three minute time
advantage in the opening turned
converted into a three second advantage
in the endgame but that three seconds in
Jennifer
Magnus Carlsen has to win with white
we've seen we have more next week more
thrilling glitch and rapid in action in
chess960 with a headline match being
garry kasparov errs world number 2
Viviano carolina but some other great
matches as well with a return of linear
Dominguez and Peter's Fiddler's will
also be returning to st. Louis not as a
commentator but as a participant in the
960 which he also did become a finalist
in the World Championship the other day
via Beach Escom qualified exactly and
where do they call it chess960 well
because there are 960 positions where
you can shuffle the pieces on the 1st
and 8th ranks to create a new starting
position and the king has to be the
between the two rooks to permit castling
long as well as cast like short also
called Fisher random chess also called
Fisher n demand one of the cool things
about our 960 events is that we played
the same position all day so we do get
to explore that a little bit and you
know go through you know perhaps like
prepper preparations yeah what's the
best day they want of a position then
the next day and then the next day we
get a new position so for new starting
positions by the way I'm looking at our
grand chest or Twitter and of course
some of the players and the Sinquefield
Cup are watching this playoff and
onigiri hit a witty you reply to
maurices question why does Magnus
Carlsen usually lose Lonnie says to get
to the other side understand what it
feels like once in a while and now did
he lose today to get to the other side
what do you think ya know Magnus wants
the 1 1 but what does Magnus gonna have
to do to get there to the 1 1 Murray's
well first of all he has to avoid being
down on the clock in every single game
so far so far doing the rain has pressed
him like I said the slight edge going to
ding Loran every single game in the
rapid both games in the rapid and now
this one as well his uncertainty is back
he's not in flow the word is flow Magnus
has to be going whoo-hoo when he's doing
that that's the Magnus Carlsen at his
peak nobody beats him but if he's not in
flow if he's stopping he's hesitating
spending a minute on moves the move
you're taking time on right now is
you're probably not going to be a losing
move in blitz you don't you don't need a
100% type moves you don't even need 95
percent type moves even 90 is not enough
one of the acara Nakamura is greatest
trends one of the things you admire the
most about him is he'll play the 80%
type move this move may not be the
perfect move but it's good enough and we
see them starting but the good enough
move that you can play quickly and you
can get in that nice flow as now big
Larry knows I get a drawer I win the
match Magnus has to win Magnus has to
get an absolute flow fluidity play fast
every move Bing Bing Bing get an answer
on the clock that's how he's going to
put the pressure on his opponent all
right
he's going into a Rui Lopez close
position with no trades yes I think this
is just what the doctor ordered for
Magnuson and must win situation the
first set of trading happening right now
and he's gotten into actually a mainline
position without the tempo h2 h3 this
chigorin variation and so well blacks in
the mainline position without rook e1 on
the board
rook e8 we can imagine Knight c3 and
again Magna is grabbing a pawn fidgeting
and it looks like he's going into d4 d5
very good just gaining some space and
saying to dinkler in okay I'm I'm going
to get a central wedge and we're gonna
play a very very long game that's is I'm
gonna keep as many pieces right borders
long that's right as I possibly can
trade no trade but keep the edge on the
claw as well don't know a perfect moves
don't look for perfect moves look for
enduring moves when you're in the
setting kit just keep the game going and
your opponent knows if he if he doesn't
make the draw he's gonna be devastated
he just won this game is this golden
opportunity so just let him beg for the
draw as long as you can and we see that
Magnus again has strategies very very
clear keep as many pawn many pieces on
the board for as long as possible knight
on a five was misplaced
Knight b7 seeking to played in 95 and if
you play b2 before you don't want to do
that too many traits exactly G yeah baby
giving up his life to keeping the pieces
I don't like this decision at all by
Magnus take that Bishop on d3 the money
Bishop is opening play b4 and Queen B 5
and black is for choice before would you
one place you need that bishop in me I
mean Bobby Fischer would be like
recoiling giving up that King's Bishop
no Queen trade says magnus carlsen oh
yes I want to see that rook a seven
rooks e7 or rooks e7 rook c8 double up
on the C file hit that C 2 square
ignoring the kingside threats Knight a5
no big deal you can just drop back with
this Bishop or even capture on f5 Magnus
looking terrible at this moment he
senses that he has given away those
light squares
how does he dominate the dark squares
conversely with the lack having such a
great dark square confirmation that it
doesn't seem very likely Bishop to e3
doubling rooks and c2 has now become
sensitive the problem is is that for
ding Larrin his moves are very natural
they he doesn't have to really think at
all about what's going on here is just
play g6 to stop any not then Knight f5
potentials or now being rolled out
behind on the clock so the flow is not
in here for him either and it's that big
giving up that Bishop those light
squares b3 dice on a Heuer the light
squares like this what a night on c4
Knight c4 at least he will block the C
file once this Knight gets to c4 I like
this move - but the thing for Magnus I
think this this game it's not the
problem with the clock it's his his King
side attacking potential is he hasn't
gotten anything started yet yeah I mean
while doing the Wren has just got total
control of the Queen side but how was
thing there I'm going to prevent this
idea of Knight c4 I don't think he is it
just be 5 yeah just to nudge that night
away from the blockading blocking the C
file and that will be a great idea
because if we get the C file then we can
start invading so 94 Bishop b5 he's
gonna have to play merit 86 is
is the night where is the night on a
five big surprise for for ourselves
okay queen bee eight and now Magnus is
saying Queen d2 Magnus is reaching
across the board wants to play Queen
takes before but rooks III looks like a
money move exactly and there it is now
you can't play ninety two don't forget
that night on g3 is protecting the night
the pawn on e4 and by the way
Bishop d8 is on ding Lauren's agenda so
a3 played anticipating that at Bishop da
we can take on before exactly I'm a trap
too by the way is it sound if you take
on a three-night c6 Knight c6
interrupting that if any has done it
he's daring Magnus now to win an
imagined has to play nighty-night c6
magnet Magnus has no charity the the
situation the match demands him to play
this double leg we're also gonna win
efore aren't we we got so much rough
take c6 Bishop takes c6 both both in
capture exactly a Knight takes e4 and
that's a great light square bishop so
rook on c3 just blown up and certainly
this is good news for magnet that movie
six he's got to recalibrate his emotions
right now he's control it's awesome for
black and how it's just like they're
gonna be wild a little mayhem he's
nervous he wants to find the move that
get the draw by the way there's gonna be
a Bishop g5 at the end hitting the night
so I'm not making it easy for you to get
that efore pawn in the variation and a
bishop takes a discovered attack against
the Queen but Queen d3.js more positive
[Music]
reasoning so what do you do here queen
5:23 we have Queen takes b3 better than
Bishop b3 allowing where p1 okay
very crucial decision here and once
again the clock times pretty close
pretty close two and a half minutes for
both sides well you wouldn't believe
anyone for taking a little bit of a
thing here because this is perhaps the
money moment of the game absolutely the
critical agreed okay five is apparently
his best move Queen a five looks boxed
hitting everything yeah
Queen a five hits the bishop hits the
pawn on a six hits upon his Carlsen a
blitz this is the flow he wants put the
pressure and now big decisions
efore do I get e4 what about base three
more walks into g5g for g5 I can't play
Bishop I got it Reed
I got to play Bishop b3 or Bishop b7 I
think I actually be careful because you
open up the position Levi Jake you not
win because of Bishop a8 a fantastic
retreating move the idea of Queen b7
Magnus has to be on the lookout if he
plays g5 a magnificent retreat will be
just fine and it's been five was a
winner
I miss Bishop a are the moves we talked
about that we've seen it in the same
field couple would be amazing if this is
the move that does it he's not winning
however he is not totally winning it's a
sacrifice and Maggie's took an 86 though
that one is worse for him as Knight 95
he five in black is back in business
black is on top Bishop e7 play quickly
by Magnus in still he's playing these
moves like he had it on foot what
happens on he's played Queen c7 by the
way yes best move all the right moves by
the way
night-night d7 Oh lots of threats Magnus
in a real trouble and he's allowed this
position yes yeah he's perfectly fine
but this is this is Lawson hold on that
it is still an a3 pond on the board guys
yes there is
Wow how can this possibly be good for
white and Bishop takes g5 and night at
for lots of it turns out that he is okay
is Magnus but a draw is not enough
remember he must win so magnificent
defense is not gonna get it done and
blacks pieces look amazing he's
coordinating everything defends each
other it's not you're on d6 now Bishop
f4 whoa that's a spectacular shot
winning the game the game is over
Queen D Aegis spy track d7 rook h1 is
made to amazing retreating moves and
it's over Magnus Kidd resigned
we're sorry f3 Bishop e3 and that's it
the same thing that's it
oh what a breakthrough for this fine
young man these are the beat Magnus to
zero this game was phenomenal fantastic
simply fantastic the best this is chess
it I can't remember the first game the
first three games of the playfield Cup
champions Ingmar n Wow congratulations
we're gonna have to call him mr. ding
to beat the world champion in a blitz
playoff and those moves Bishop
[Applause]
anytime soon as this celebration will
certainly be long I mean this is just an
incredible tournament victory for the
Chinese number one who's now mum
rocketing up on the Blitz ranking is as
well I mean we're gonna have to see what
the Blitz rank ratings look after he had
this 2-0 victory over Carlos an historic
achievement for ganglia and a
career-best beating the world champion
in a playoff it just doesn't get any
better what great sportsmanship from
Magnus Carlsen and he actually smiled
after he lost the game I mean come on
don't want to beat you like that well
but it was those last two moves to that
did it look at this moment when Magnus
played Queen takes d6 and he's thinking
to himself oh it's so sweet he's gonna
play Queen to d8 check and take this
pawn with check Bishop f4 and then
Magnus saw this move Bishop c5 so he's
got mate in one on the board and I'm
hanging bishop and the fish hanging
bishop and the bishops under attack so
Magnus thinking rook takes e5 Queen
takes e5 he's gonna win tie the match up
look out 97 Desmond the night on g3
defends h1 but the night on g1 is pinned
anonymously Queen takes rook mate Wow
beautiful final one big finish that is
just that's just that's a spectacular I
mean it was great an incredible game no
doubt that gave big Moran the victory
here in Singh field cuppa right now we
have with us the runner-up world
champion Magnus Carlsen absolutely epic
battle indeed Magnus this was amazed
battle between two of the top players in
the world yeah I gotta say he was a lot
better than I was today so he won
absolutely deservedly normally you say
flow is the problem when you get in flow
it looked like you weren't getting that
that natural flow you usually get in
wrapping in bliss no but it has to do
something
it has something to do obviously with
the fact that he's a very good player
but yeah clearly I had I had a very
difficult day too
today I couldn't get anything going I
was thinking too long and mainly just
defending in in most of my games so yeah
it wasn't it wasn't close your your
thoughts about your overall performance
though in the Sinquefield Cup you did
make a run at it winning the last two
games when you had to yeah exactly so
that's why I cannot feel too
disappointed now I would have loved to
win today but I managed to do to salvage
quite a bit in the last today so I'm not
too disappointed - thank you very much
great comeback and thrilling us as
always look forward to seeing you in a
little bit of trash-talking mode and
ultimately alright our congratulations
to you to magnets for a very very fine
performance to get yourself into this
playoff let's just take a look at that
final moment when Magnus played this
move g5 and literally when he played
that move we were thinking oh that's a
winner until we saw Bishop 88 all the
way back to lock and load on the on the
long diagonal with Queen b7 and that's
saved that's like a super battery
threatening checkmate and doing the
right I love the way he played it so
quickly he had seen g5 and he
anticipated Bishop a8 that's brilliant
I mean it's brilliantly in a blitz game
plays C moves like that Wow Wow and then
at the end of the game another
retreating
97 that solution takes these six and you
see I think matters might realize it
himself but something's off in this
position if he threatens checkmate
but now doing the ran with 97
threatening work h1 mate and it's just
defending the bishop on c6 as well what
a moment - what a move 97 turns the
tables again and we have our sink filled
cup winner that's right
ding Moran our new sink filled cup
champion is with Maurice new indeed we
have a new face new name on the sink
filled cup yet again ding the reign of
China getting it done first of all
congratulations on your victory thank
you
how does it feel of course it feels very
good after playing and such a good game
I were very happy to play the final
final game with fire not about just
setup for Joe I survived it too but I
have to pray because the initiative and
have to fight for the job it was a
struggle you played some amazing moves
the move Bishop takes e4 you saw Bishop
a8 coming very quickly yeah
first I miss queeny 5 I thought it was a
very pointy four but then I realize here
I do 235 pounds I do Bishop a right and
he actually went right into it and then
later you sacrifice your queen for the
two rooks what what were you feeling
right there was not a sacrifice but
traded for the two rogues what did you
feel what your position was like then
since I didn't want to exchange the
Queen's we couldn't be 7 so I want to
exchange his rules and he prays look
healthy ones then I have to take and
after takes then I started I had to
think after exchange
you see it here you play this line with
Bishop to f4 when did you see 97 he
played Bishop c5 did you see it when he
played it I think I saw this when I
finish up g5 but I just couldn't
couldn't I didn't have time to make sure
I just thought it's winning and then I
just go for it with her hands if I
didn't have 97 then maybe I lost it was
that kind of double edge moment yeah but
if I didn't check into Cal Poly I just
pray with intuition and now that we call
that flow and you drop a piece on and
it's just working for you what does it
mean for you personally to win the city
oka I haven't expected since during the
first two or three games my I think my
prey was not that good again karaoking I
was much worse and against Russia also
our better out of opening but I cannot
find out the plan audience say I will
you know her good shape but when my win
against the NH gave me a lot of
confidence and this was okay this was
the kind of game I used to play and I
that's what my
my third kind of precipitations yeah yes
I've prayed well
so after University I sometimes I
started to thought about the considering
the chunking and considering to win the
tournament but it's not so realistic
until I beat Fabiano after this I will
co-leader positions and then I just want
to draw all the games and at least two
time for first but then you had to play
Magnus Carlsen making a comeback that
must have been nerve-racking as well
Magnus has never lost a tie-break you
were the first person to ever defeat him
in a tie-break yes I know this he has
win 10 out of 10 more than 10 years
incredible I mean that must give you a
great feeling yeah but today are much
different than yesterday since yesterday
I said before I was really stressed out
since yesterday I'm playing a tournament
but today I just play a match yeah so I
just finished the tournament with the
very good results then I just went for
more and it's like a bonus yeah I got
in price and also the achieve achieved
any name and so today I just feel
relaxed yes and I enjoy this deed what
do you feel about your fans back in
China your teammates the Olympic
teammates you led them to the the
Olympic the Olympia title this year are
they cheering right now in China I don't
know I didn't check the mobile phone I
think I will receive many come graduates
I think you will indeed congratulations
on a fantastic result you're the
champion yeah congratulations and we're
in our congratulations as well it was a
fantastic success a career achievement
and for Chinese chess also something
extra special does it make you want to
think about world championship match
title and maybe playing Magnus a match
for the title one day
yeah the first I had to win candidates I
know one level and he bet he plays very
good in the Coast tournament but in
every candidates that he didn't perform
well he prayed very bad so you have to
avoid that yourself
still you must hope one day to become
the world champion alright I know he's
the humble humble person you are
did you have a question yeah during the
round just such a wonderful tiebreak I
think that might have been that was the
most entertaining tirade I've ever
called you played so fantastically would
you say that with your best blitz game
ever maybe the third game during the
police game actually I was lucky since
he flagged I didn't see when maybe the
final possession were hard to win
already and mr. Winn I think and when I
returned told him that he lost some time
there just I was very surprised since I
just focus on the games and not only to
cook well in the second game was just
absolutely magnificent
seriously one that people will remember
for a long time again our
congratulations wow Jennifer the what an
entertaining
playoff we just witnessed that was just
something amazing this is how it all
drains out 80 $2,500 for ding Lauren and
most importantly the Sinquefield Cup
title P is 7 Sinquefield Cup champion
but 6 ever to win it clear just a
fantastic performance the best high
break I've ever seen I mean in terms of
those blitz games and particular she's
just off the chart ridiculous I mean my
quality stuff but let's go through the
list of all of the players beginning
with Wesley so Jenny well Wesley so tied
for last in this tournament you know he
actually started off very solidly but
with those two losses towards the end
he's gonna have to recalibrate and try
to do well in the last two events
to qualify for the Manchester finals
still with very good chances exactly
Levon Aronian almost the exact same
scenario bad thing filled Cup but he's
the st. Louis rapping and blitz champion
he'll go home with that title for sure
but really disappointing levar here as
he was hoping to take our home a lot
more Grantchester points he too is gonna
have to work to get to London and Hikaru
Nakamura unfortunately for his fans are
defending Grantchester champions is no
longer in the race to London but he will
be playing in India and potentially
unseating magnus carlsen in that event
exactly at the very disappointing out in
for America's a u.s. champion and we've
got Maxine bossy or the grab definitely
a disappointment for mvl as well
tournament that could have been I mean
all kinds of roller roller coaster rides
for MBL that's he's hoping to get to
London but boy he's just barely clinging
on it's out of his hands now you will
have to focus on all those other events
and just you know pray that somehow he
does get it to get to London and Neogene
here who experienced ups and downs this
was the most a fight decisive player of
the tournament Jennifer for Nepal Miyake
is that he played the most decisive
games six out of 12 in terms of the
number of minutes spent yes definitely
has the best resolve like no question so
wins per minute this guy he's got the
ratio down pat wow he really could have
had a result a spectacular result he'll
be extremely disappointed with it this
50% score it's so great to have any
minute tournament gets he's so emotive
and so dynamic and so different than
everyone else no question about it
Jacques we are Oh mommy they are us
Azerbaijan Shaq with one of the most
dynamic players in the world used to
winning and losing he goes through the
entire competition
cause this has got to be in my opinion a
career first for Shaq is he happy or
unhappy Jen mixed feeling mixed feelings
okay but for his Gretchen had Chester a
chance is not great another player on an
even score is on each giri who won that
final game against ya and the poem that
she and we had dinner last night with
Aisha and a second flat American couch
Allah and under said you know it was a
struggle the entire tournament was a
struggle I was behind the eight-ball all
the time the win he's so happy that he
got out of here with fifty percent score
and he's feeling confident as he's going
on to Russia and the World Cup
Fabiano Carolina no doubt disappointing
for him as he was in the hunt for
another Cup in this tournament but
unfortunately without a base two rounds
and is actually threatening to get a -
score as he was really on the ropes
against Sergei car yeah I can manage to
draw that game and with even Stevens and
car yeah can quiet assassin like kind of
creeping up the cross tables in both the
rapid and blitz and the Ziegfeld Cup
saying like hey I'm here there's a
chance mister real real golden
opportunity to get into the playoff as
he was winning that 11th game but only
made a draw against Fabiano he'll go
home with mixed feelings but also
feeling good about his overall results
and okay and with another player tied
for third but in this case no doubt very
disappointed because he had such
wonderful sparkling opening in
preparation and middle gameplay but
unfortunately was not able to convert
enough and therefore did not find
himself at the top of the winner's
circle but still tied for third $35,000
and now with a very good chance to you
know make it into the finals in London
if he does well well in the rest of the
tour he said it well himself he's at
undefeated plus-one I feel gutted my
technique
than me it wasn't there I could have had
+6 if Magnus had the positions that I
got he said he wasn't a deserving winner
vichy undefeated he's got the biggest
sink build on losing streak in the
history yes and here we have our
runner-up world champion Magnus Carlsen
has never lost a tie-break but today
there's a first for everything he did
lose to an incredibly well prepared and
determined being I ran that Magnus you
got to give up all the credit in the
world he did nothing in the tournament
nine consecutive draws winning on-demand
with white but then doing this near
impossible winning on demand with black
to get himself into a playoff tip your
hat to Magnus Carlsen an extraordinary
performance he lit up our final round
and here is our champion congratulations
to ding Lauren who takes home 80 $2,500
a great position on the grand chest
Tory's now overall in second and this
prestigious Singh field cup title he is
now the seventh champion and the sixth
sole winner
yes and what a group he has now joined
absolutely his name on the trophy and
here is the GCT standings with the
Sinquefield cup now firmly in the books
well Magnus Carlsen and Engler in
looking fabulous to get to London but
it's all about who's gonna get those
third and fourth spots as the fight for
them will certainly be ferocious big big
contenders include Vishy Anand Levon
Aronian and Wesley so as they all have
two events left to play so if they were
to do well in two events that they would
take one of those three in four spots
but final thoughts on this thrilling
month really but couple weeks of chess
here in st. Louis from or exactly well
who could have imagined when two years
ago ding Lauren came to st. Louis and
played Magnus Carlsen our rapid and
blitz match and was absolutely pasted
there's no other way to put it
completely crushed final score 17 to
who in that combined event Hey look
disconsolate dejected and simply
down-and-out
still this guy's never gonna challenge
magnus carlsen in this fear two years
later he stands atop the st. Louis
audience everyone say amazing taking
down a man who had never ever lost a
tie-break ten Oh in tiebreaks
he comes and pulls off one of the great
upsets of the ages and by the way he
also knocks Magnus Carlsen down from
number two in the world as he himself
rises to the number two spot in blitz on
the planet mere percentage points
actually three point five around points
behind the Kaoru Nakamura now we know if
he ever plays Magnus in a World
Championship and they tie oh don't think
there's a big edge there from Magnus as
ding Lauren also played extremely well
in the st. Louis rapid and blitz simply
a deserving champ to be sure amazing
chess
he played we will not forget Bishop may
8 and 97 I could tell you those moves
were spectacular he said he just played
it by hand he sees amazing moves of
course he's 2,800 watch him climb up the
rating ladder as well the two weeks were
amazing the first eight rounds not so
much but after that we were thrilled
guys and I am as always pleased to be
part of this team it's so much fun to
work with two of the best in the
business and can't wait for more trash
talking and more chess next week gary is
borrowers in town we got something
coming up than 30 minutes baby talking
about the ultimate moves Jennifer well
when he said the best in the business I
thought he was talking about Tom over at
silverback John Jesse
Randy of course at Spectrum Studios who
you'll see in just a few minutes your
ultimate moves he also had David and
Paul we had version of Kobe on giving us
awesome great opening insights Jen and
the studio and we also had Rosen
who filled in for var briefly all right
yeah yeah so many names on the list you
have in and Justin just incredible
directors of photography who always
somehow make even us look good and
really really big things to the world
chess Hall of Fame for all of those
historical photos that they allowed us
to use for the fireside chats as well
all the people here on staff at the st.
Louis chess club who constantly make us
feel at home
yes led by Julian Toni and of course
there was Rebecca back and Emily Tata's
who did all of the social media as well
as the Chronicle Leonards as well making
sure those with beautiful photos for
your interest and Christian Sharia and
the other commentators and Mira mural
Brian Marcus there's just so many people
with that matrix have been Simon and
Isaac as well for making the Russian
commentary so much fun as well and
whoever we forgot don't worry we're
gonna get your name in there because we
got chess960 coming up exactly and I
can't wait that's gonna be and starting
on September 2nd but for now go get
lunch and enjoy one of the most fun
events that we cover ultimate moves with
the sting field showdown and one garry
kasparov joining the action i got to
tell you with gary it is one heck of an
event all the moves with gary is just
that extra element to make it completely
breathtaking that I'm running away we'll
see you in just about a half hour for
ultimate moves
[Music]